Moin, Leute.
Oh, ich hab Arsch, ey.
Monka ist...
Ja, 10 Kilometer sind doch immer recht anstrengend, auch wenn man es nicht übertreibt.
Bin gespannt. Mein Ziel ist demnächst ja mal hier eine Runde zu rennen.
11 Kilometer hin, 11 Kilometer zurück.
Mit Pause.
Und was trinken dazwischen.
Boah, mal gucken, wie das wird, ey.
Ich nehme auf jeden Fall das Handy mit, falls ich abgeholt werden muss.
Moin.
Un-S-D-Company.
Pog.
Du siehst Rosebikes. Ja, siehst du richtig.
Ich hab gestern wieder ein Fahrrad.
Gestern wieder ein Fahrrad gekauft.
Gibt's mittlerweile Di2? Das gibt es die ganze Zeit schon.
Was es nicht gibt, ist 1x12 und 2x12 als Di2.
Das ist das Ding. Das ist das, was ich eigentlich haben wollte.
Was ich mir jetzt gekauft habe, ist exakt das gleiche.
Das gleiche Fahrrad, wie ich vorher hatte.
Nur, weil das einzige Lieferbare waren noch 2x11.
Und, ähm, mal gucken, wann das andere rauskommt.
Hat ja auch keinen Sinn, da jetzt ewig zu warten.
Oh Mann, ich bin voll im Arsch, Leute.
Oh, ich seh's gerade.
So, meine Pille nehmen.
Nein, nix Schlimmes.
Vitamine.
Macht eigentlich überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Es ist, äh, ich nehme ab und zu so...
Was ist das? Vitamin D?
Ist das, glaube ich?
Was ist das, was man anstatt Sonne nimmt?
Ich nehme da einmal die Woche im Winter eine.
Auch wenn das sehr umstritten ist, ob das überhaupt was bringt.
Schaden wird's wahrscheinlich nix.
Zumal heute viel Sonne war.
Lass mich mal kurz gucken in meinen Fitness-Tracker, wie das heute lief.
Heute war echt nicht schnell und anstrengend.
Heute war das Gegenteil von letzter Woche.
Letzte Woche war übel schnell und nicht so wild.
Ähm.
Und heute war anstrengend und nicht so schnell.
Hier.
Zehn Kilometer.
Eine Stunde vier.
Schatz.
Also mein Garmin-Ding meint, die zweite Hälfte war Minus-Performance-Condition.
Aber das meint es bei der Runde immer, weil die zweite Hälfte geht über eins, zwei längere Brücken nochmal drüber.
Es geht quasi die zweite Hälfte mehr berghoch als die erste Hälfte.
Und irgendwie denkt es dann dadurch, dass ich langsamer bin und höheren Puls habe, Minus-Performance-Condition.
Immer die zweite Hälfte von der Runde.
Aber passt schon.
Man, reicht jetzt, ey.
Bestimmt.
Aber es ist trotzdem anstrengend.
Also mein Plan ist tatsächlich, wenn es mal ein bisschen wärmer wird wieder.
Also wenn es mal so schönes Wetter, 15 Grad oder so ist.
Sonnenschein, 15 Grad.
Da habe ich mir schon eine Runde ausgeguckt.
Da sind elf Kilometer hin, elf Kilometer zurück.
Von Hanau nach Seligenstadt.
Am Main.
Dem Main-Radweg.
Also das ist kein Main-Radweg.
Main-Weg.
Ja, aber da kann man auch Fahrrad fahren und laufen und so.
Elf Kilometer hin, elf Kilometer zurück.
Mein Plan ist, also ich muss auf jeden Fall ein bisschen Wasser mitnehmen.
So irgendwie mit keinem halben Liter oder so.
Man muss es ja nicht übertreiben.
Wenn ich ein bisschen was trinken kann.
Ich habe so was, ich habe so was Kleines, wie man, wo man sich das so in die, in so eine Westentasche stecken kann.
Und dann mache ich da kurz Pause.
Hol vielleicht ein Eis oder so, keine Ahnung.
Und dann, zehn Minuten später, renne ich wieder zurück.
Mal gucken, wie gut das läuft.
Ja, ist es auch.
Ist es auch.
Also ich habe jetzt, ich habe mir gestern das hier gekauft.
Das hier ist mein altes Fahrrad gewesen, das ist das, was kaputt ist, wegen Unfall und keiner, also keiner, also alle sagen, mit dem Carbonrahmen sollte ich nicht mehr auf die Straße gehen, nachdem das einmal vom Auto angefahren wurde.
Das ist das alte, das ist das neue.
Man sieht, es ist, also mehr oder weniger das gleiche Fahrrad.
Es ist eins, also es unterscheiden sich ein paar Sachen.
Das ist ein anderer Sattel.
Aber das ist, wenn mir der neue Sattel nicht gefällt, dann.
Nehme ich einfach den alten wieder, es ist ja der gleiche Rahmen.
Es sind andere Reifen.
Es ist, äh, zweimal elf Schaltung und hat ein bisschen kleinere Bremsklötze, warum auch immer.
Oder täuscht das auf dem Bild einfach nur, Leute?
Täuscht das oder sind die wirklich ein bisschen kleiner?
Die Bremsbeläge da, die Bremsscheiben oder wie das genau, ein bisschen minimal kleiner sind die.
Jaja, also immer.
Ja, da habe ich das gerade drauf stehen.
Ich habe hier so einen, einen Swift, nee, wie heißt das Ding, Wahoo, ein Wahoo Kicker Core.
Da steht das drauf, da steht hier schräg hinter mir, das alte, weil für Indoor-Fahren ist das noch vollkommen fein.
Das einzige, was ich nach dem Unfall machen musste, man sieht es hier, glaube ich, äh, guckt das Teil hier unten, wo die Schaltung dranhängt, das musste ich austauschen.
Das war nämlich verbogen, deswegen hat das nicht mehr richtig geschaltet.
Das habe ich ausgetauscht und let's go.
Jetzt fährt es wieder.
Ahem.
Das steht auf, gerade auf dem Smart-Trainer und ich fahre da öfters.
Swift ist tatsächlich eines der wenigen Abos, die ich habe und die ich ganz normal bezahle, ohne irgendwelche Tricks.
Ja, YouTube wird über Indien bezahlt und sonst, wobei Prime, Prime bezahle ich auch ganz normal.
Aber ich habe wenige Abos, ich versuche so wenig Abos wie möglich abzuschließen, ich mache überall, wenn ich ein Abo abschließe, weil ich irgendwas gucken will oder irgendeine Dienstleistung, was auch immer, in Anspruch nehme.
Ich schließe immer das Abo ab und cancel direkt wieder.
Ich lasse nie Abos laufen.
Abo, äh, sonst Abofalle.
Hat der Rahmen sichtbare Schäden?
Am Wann fangen beide Schäden an?
Er hat ein paar Kratzer, paar kleine Kratzer, also er hat keine Risse, keine offensichtlichen
oder so.
Aber das, aber sogar der Gutachter sagt, Totalschaden.
Also ich glaube denen das mal.
Wahrscheinlich wird der Abo ab, aber das ist eben nicht so.
Ich habe es auch nicht.
Ich würde nichts passieren, aber es wäre doof, wenn ich fahre und irgendwie ein bisschen
härter irgendwo drauf und dann bricht irgendwas ab am Rahmen.
Das wäre ziemlich kacke.
Ja, immer, immer direkt Subscription canceln.
Egal ob Netflix oder Onlyfans.
Immer direkt Subscription canceln.
Natürlich außer bei mir auf Twitch.
So, ich mache mal kurz Package Updates, weil Arch Linux, by the way, gibt bestimmt neue
Package.
Packages.
Man muss das ja immer.
Uptodate Pleading Edge halten.
Ist ja.
Moin, Calimero, was gibt es denn auf YouTube heute für Empfehlungen?
Ihr habt.
Warte mal, ich sollte mir doch irgendwas angucken.
Hier, der Chat hat doch gestern gesagt, der Anzeige Hauptmeister soll ich mir angucken.
Zwei Millionen in vier Tagen.
Okay, da muss ja echt was her.
Apple TV heute braucht es noch jemand.
Die Sache ist eher umgedreht.
Hat das schon mal jemand?
Hat jemals jemand gebraucht?
Das ist die Frage, die ich mir stelle.
Ja, das wäre halt genau.
Es passiert dann im ungünstigsten Moment.
Das passiert nicht so nach dem Motto Ach, ich fahre jetzt mal los.
Ich bin eh noch langsam geradeaus.
Das passiert dann in ungünstigen Sachen so in der Kurve irgendwie über den Huppel und
dann bricht irgendwas ab.
Und dann fliegst du aufs Maul.
Also als Saro.
Danke schön für den Sub.
Und dann fliegst du aufs Maul.
Und dann.
Und dann geht's geht irgendwas richtig kaputt und nicht nur am Fahrrad, sondern an dir.
Aber ich finde es nice, ich freue mich richtig, wenn das neue Fahrrad da ist, weil ich habe
im Vergleich zum alten Fahrrad habe ich.
Ich habe knapp 1000 € gespart, gespart, gespart kann man es nicht nennen.
Im Endeffekt bin ich immer noch 2600 € los, aber das alte Fahrrad hat 3500 gekostet, zwar
das hier.
Das hat 3500 gekostet.
Das alte Fahrrad und ich kriege ja insgesamt von der Versicherung das jetzt zurück plus
Ausfall.
Ja, und Anwalt und Gutachten müssen sie auch bezahlen.
Das ist mittlerweile.
Das ist mittlerweile schon bei, glaube ich, fast 6000 € alles zusammen und die haben
immer noch nicht bezahlt.
Das wird immer teurer für die jeden Tag, wo die nicht bezahlen, wird es immer teurer.
Bald ist das bald ist das zweite ist das neue Fahrrad komplett auch auch quasi noch oben
drauf.
Er nennt sich Girl Math.
Warum ist das Moment ist Girl Math das, was früher mein Opa Milchmädchen Rechnung genannt
hat.
Nennt man das heute Girl Math?
Mein Opa hatte eh die übelst old school old school Wörter.
Ich habe es ja letztens schon gesagt.
Da hat mein Opa immer mit Schandzeug gesagt und er hat auch nicht gesagt, jetzt wird's
aber Zeit, sondern hat gesagt es pressiert gut.
Ich meine, wann ist mein Opa auf die Welt gekommen?
Gute Frage 1920 oder so hat man mein Opa wäre jetzt wäre jetzt 100 über 100 wäre der 1922
oder so wurde mein ist mein Opa auf die Welt gekommen.
Also sprich, da hat man halt noch so altertümlich geredet.
Ja.
Es pressiert ist noch voll okay.
Ernsthaft.
Vielleicht kommt das auch noch aus dem Krieg.
Der hat Besteck immer Schandzeug genannt.
Vielleicht ist das so ein so ein also ein Militär Slang gewesen, der irgendwie bei ihm
hängen geblieben ist aus dem zweiten Weltkrieg.
Keine Ahnung.
Vielleicht.
Ja, keine Ahnung.
Vielleicht kommt das ja von da.
Keine keine Updates mehr Reboot.
Mein Opa war eh der allerbeste Diskotheker.
Ja.
Wenn er, wenn er recht hatte, ich glaube, das habe ich schon mal erzählt, wenn er recht
hatte, hatte, hatte am Ende von irgendeiner Diskussion immer gesagt Ja, der Opa hat für
gewöhnlich recht.
Und wenn er mich nicht davon überzeugen konnte, dass er recht hatte oder er keinen Bock mehr
hatte oder er festgestellt hat, er hat Mist erzählt, hat er immer gesagt Ja, ja, du hast
recht und ich habe meine Ruhe.
Und dann hat er keinen Bock mehr gehabt.
Ja, ja, ja.
Also das war eigentlich unmöglich für meinen Opa, nicht recht zu haben.
Zwar bei Design war das.
Hard coded.
Das ging nicht.
Entweder hatte er keinen Bock mehr, hat er nur noch gesagt Ja, ja, ja, lass mich in Ruhe
oder oder.
Ja, der Opa hat für gewöhnlich recht.
Also eigentlich, du konntest eigentlich nicht nicht gewinnen in dem Sinn bei irgendeiner Diskussion
mit meinem Opa.
Ja.
Aber und das muss man halt auch mein Opa war halt übelster Sparfuchs.
Ja, der hat.
Der hat bei allem gespart.
Ich glaube, das kommt alles aber so, das kam bei dem garantiert auch noch eben aus der
Nachkriegszeit.
Ich glaube, wenn du das mal alles mitgemacht hast, also Krieg und Nachkriegszeit, wenn
du das mal alles mitgemacht hast, da siehst du die Welt ein bisschen anders.
Und der konnte zum Beispiel auch nicht langsam essen.
Das war einfach nicht drinne.
Ja.
Und das kommt garantiert noch aus dem Krieg und nach dem Krieg.
Der konnte nicht langsam essen.
Also ich weiß noch, der war bei uns ab und zu zu Silvester daheim zu Gast dann, ja, als
die Oma schon nicht mehr gelebt hat, war der Opa teilweise bei uns an Silvester.
Und da haben wir Raclette gemacht, also das 0815-Standards-Heuch, was gefühlt irgendwie
90% der Deutschen an Silvester machen, haben wir früher auch gemacht.
Das ist, ihr kennt das, das sind so mit so Förmchen in so einen Grill reinstellen.
Dann belegt man so Förmchen und dann macht man Käse drauf und grillt die so.
So und das Ding war.
Da stand dann halt immer alles mögliche Zeug auf dem Tisch rum, ja.
Pilze, Schinken, äh, Maisdinger, alle mögliche Zeug, das hat man nicht so auf die Förmchen
gemacht und rein.
Das Ding war, mein Opa konnte nicht langsam essen.
Das ging nicht.
Also es war ein Ding der Unmöglichkeit für den, eineinhalb Stunden zu essen.
Das lief immer so ab, wir haben den, wir haben den abgeholt, haben den Grill angemacht und
auch während der Grill aufgeheizt hat.
Hat er schon angefangen, äh, die rohen Pilze, Gurken und Käsedinger zu futtern, die eigentlich
zum Grillen da waren und da hab ich dann immer gemeint, ja Opa, jetzt warte doch mal, mach
doch mal langsam, mach doch mal langsam und da meinte er immer so, ja, ja, äh, richtet
euch nicht nach mir, macht, macht ihr einfach so, wie ihr wollt, ja und nach einer Viertelstunde
und vielleicht eins, zwei Förmchen war der fertig und dann hat er eine Stunde da gesessen
und sich gelangweilt.
Und dann kam's, da gab's dann immer so die Diskussionen wie.
Ähm, ja, Opa, willst du, sollen wir dich zwischendurch heimbringen, sollen wir dich heimbringen?
Hat er, hat er immer gesagt, nee, nee, ich richte mich ganz nach euch, mach dir langsam.
Und fünf Minuten später hat er gesagt, oh, jetzt wird's aber doch langsam Zeit.
Ja, willst du heim?
Nee, nee, ich richte mich ganz nach euch.
Ja, aber langsam könnte man doch mal, das war so hübelswidersprüchlich immer, hatte
eigentlich keinen Bock mehr, aber er wollte halt nicht zu uns sagen, auf jetzt, macht
mal hinne.
Der konnte halt einfach nicht langsam essen, das ging nicht.
Ja.
Und ich weiß noch, einmal, als der, als er zum Mittagessen da war, hab ich gedacht, ich
muss den, ich muss den Notarzt rufen, weil der seine Spaghetti so schnell gefuttert hat.
Nee, nee, nee, das ist garantiert irgendeine Kriegs- und Nachkriegsgeschichte mit diesem
Schnellessen.
Und es gab einmal Mittagsspaghetti, war der Opa auch da und wie gesagt, mein Opa konnte
nicht langsam essen und er hat die Spaghetti quasi so schnell sich reingestopft, dass die,
die sind ihm im Hals hängen geblieben und auf einmal sitzt der am Tisch und kriegt keine
Luft mehr.
Der sitzt da, ich guck so zu meinem, guck so zu meinem Opa rüber, der sitzt da und der
sitzt so da und ich denk mir so, oh scheiße, Alter, ich glaub, der Opa erstickt.
Ich, ich dachte mir so, okay, wenn der jetzt irgendwie, wenn das noch ein bisschen länger
geht, ich, weißt du, ich halt übelst Adrenalin stoß, ja, hab ich gesagt, ich, ich, ich muss
jetzt zum Telefon vorspringen.
Und den Notarzt rufen.
Aber irgendwann so nach, keine Ahnung, nach fünf Sekunden oder so, hat er es dann wieder
auf die Reihe gekriegt, aber da hatte ich ein bisschen, hab ich ein bisschen wieder
Angst zu tun gekriegt, hab gedacht, der erstickt jetzt an der Spaghetti oder so, aber der hat
eh super krass gespart immer, ja, der hat beispielsweise auch im Winter immer schon
nachmittags.
Oder irgendwie so, ich weiß nicht genau wie, die Heizung ausgeschaltet, weil das ja Heizkosten
spart und wenn man die Tür zulässt und einmal richtig geheizt hat und so, dann, dann reicht
das für den Rest des Tages und, und so komisches Zeug.
In dem Haus war es immer kalt, obwohl er genug Heizung hat, es war immer kalt.
Im Flur war es kalt, also, by the way, das ist das Haus, in dem ich jetzt wohne hier,
es war immer kalt.
Im Schlafzimmer war es kalt.
Gut, na ja, da ist bei mir nichts.
Da ist nichts.
Das ist bei mir auch kühl, aber nicht kalt.
Kalt.
In der Küche, im Flur, kalt.
Es war überall kalt.
Das Einzige, wo ein bisschen warm war, war im Wohnzimmer, weil mein Opa halt den ganzen
Tag im Wohnzimmer war, Fernseher geguckt hat, der hat gerne Kreuzworträtsel gemacht, sowas
halt typische Opa-Tätigkeiten und es waren sogar ein paar vom Pflegedienst da, die haben
zu ihm gesagt, ja, hier, Herr Opa, Sie müssen mal ordentlich, ordentlich warm machen, das
ist zu kalt hier.
Es ist im Winter irgendwie 17 Grad.
Erkältung und alles.
Ja, und meine Vermutung ist, dass genau das meinem Opa auch letztendlich zum Verhängnis
geworden ist.
Der ist ja schon vor ein paar Jahren gestorben und zwar an einer Lungenentzündung, die wohl
dadurch ausgelöst wurde, dass er Speisereste in der Lunge hat und das in Kombination mit
zu kalter Umgebung.
Über mehrere Tage hat sich das dann hingezogen.
Wurde immer schlimmer.
Also meine Vermutung ist, dass die Kombination zu krass schnell essen und zu kalt permanent
in der Wohnung und permanentes Frieren, dass das ihm mit zum Verhängnis geworden ist am
Ende.
Natürlich, man weiß es nie, kann auch so, kann auch so irgendwas kriegen ein paar Wochen
später.
Aber die Kombination passt halt schon irgendwie.
Hm.
Nee, aber wisst ihr was?
Wisst ihr, eine Sache frage ich mich ja echt.
Ich frag mich, wie hat das eigentlich mein Opa und meine Oma, wie haben die das durchgehalten?
Wenn du dir das heute teilweise anguckst, ich bin ja auch so, ich flame ja auch über
alles, ja alles, was nicht irgendwie so so ist, wie mir das gefällt, wird geflamed.
Und ich frag mich, wie hat das, wie hat das mein Oma und mein Opa durchgehalten?
opa durchgehalten bei denen war die welt noch viel anstrengender und und viel gefährlicher
aber die haben eigentlich nie gemeckert und nicht nur ich sondern auch generell ist also
meine generation und auch deutlich jüngere generation und gerade wenn du auf twitter
und social media wirklich es wird über jeden kleinsten scheiß gemeckert als geht's um leben
oder tod ich weiß nicht bei meiner oma und meinem opa ging es wohl wirklich zwischenzeitlich um leben
und tod aber ja trotzdem nicht gemeckert der schulweg ich glaube ich glaube das ist es ja
ich glaube die wissen halt gerade noch zweiter weltkrieg und danach die wussten halt wie es ist
wenn zu richtig scheiße ist und danach war alles war alles toll also alles was danach kam war beste
ja
so dann lasst uns doch mal schauen das wollte ich sicher was trende denn auch schütter heute
sie sind nicht mit twitter aufgewachsen ja das stimmt wohl du meinst mit x ja also mein opa war
mein opa wollte sich drücken vor der wehrpflicht oder so oder wie nannte man das im zweiten
weltkrieg oder ich weiß nicht ob er sich drücken wollte ich kann es schwer sagen
wie ist das mit hessen und mit dem reinen und dem jungen um sich anzuschauen was ist denn mit dem
ja so dass man sich da einfach nicht mehr so über uns über die sicht gerät ja aber ich weiß nicht ob
der sich drücken wollte ich kann es schwer sagen ja und wo hat er so viele sachen gemacht
wie das genau war.
Aber ich weiß, sie sind geflohen
vor dem Einzug, genau.
Da wollte ich drücken, davor eingezogen zu werden.
Was ich auch voll und ganz verstehen kann,
ich hätte auch keinen Bock, in den Krieg geschickt zu werden.
Also, der ist
von daheim weg und
ist quasi geflohen
von daheim, dass sie ihn irgendwie nicht einziehen können.
Sie haben ihn aber trotzdem dann
erwischt, irgendwie.
Ich kenne die Story, der hat mir das ein paar Mal
erzählt, aber ich kriege es ja nicht richtig.
Sie sind zumindest geflohen von daheim
und die wurden dann
irgendwo
aufgegriffen unterwegs
und halt trotzdem zwangs
eingezogen, so wie das halt in
Deutschland gewesen ist. Hast du halt gelitten gehabt, wenn du in dem
passenden Alter warst. Der ist 1922
geboren, glaube ich. Sprich, der war
20 oder 18,
18, 20, wann ging der?
1942 oder wann ging
der Zweite Weltkrieg los?
1940, 1942, 1942,
oder?
39? Ach,
also, der müsste so 18, 19, 20
oder so gewesen sein, mein Opa.
Und, ja,
der war in Russland
am Start, also nicht Frankreich
oder so, der war in Russland
und eins muss man
sagen,
also,
das kann man wahrscheinlich
schwer nachvollziehen, wenn man da nicht dabei war,
aber, der hat nicht,
wie soll man das sagen? Also,
normalerweise würde ich von ausgehen, ja, wenn du,
wenn du da im Krieg gewesen bist und das war der Feind
und so, dann findest du die dein Leben lang
kacke. Aber mein Opa hat nie schlecht
über irgendwelche Russen geredet.
Also,
der fand russische, wie soll man sagen,
russische Musik, russische
Kultur und solche, fand er
super interessant, auch nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg.
Also, mein Opa fand
die russische Seite viel cooler
quasi als die Amis.
Die Amis mochte er überhaupt nicht.
Bis zum Schluss. Die Amis mochte
er gar nicht. Und das,
obwohl er im Krieg in Russland war.
Mit Sicherheit, mit Sicherheit
hat er Angst vor den Russen gehabt und die Russen
vor den Deutschen. Das war ja damals,
die wollten ja beide nicht.
Die hatten, ich glaube, das lag
bestimmt auch daran, dass beide Seiten
eigentlich, wie soll man sagen, auf
persönlicher Ebene halt so
gar nichts gegeneinander hatten.
Die mussten sich halt umbringen gegenseitig.
Es ist nicht so, dass
die sich nicht leihen konnten oder so.
Im Vorfeld. Die kannten sich ja gar nicht.
Die mussten sich halt killen gegenseitig.
Zumindest mein Opa war übelst
lucky, zumindest,
was das angeht.
Weiß nicht, ob man das glücklich nennen kann, aber irgendwo
irgendwo schon, der war, wie gesagt,
der war in Russland
und
von seiner, wie nannt man das,
Abteilung, Kompanie, was auch immer,
waren sie, also der Gruppe, frag mich nicht,
keine Ahnung. Ich weiß ja auch noch von dem,
was mein Opa erzählt hat.
Waren sie irgendwie, glaub ich, 15 Leute und nur zwei
davon haben sie überlebt?
Einer davon mein Opa. Und mein
Opa hat das Ganze überlebt.
Oder ich weiß nicht, wie 15 Leute oder irgendwie so.
Mein Opa hat das überlebt,
weil
er, sie haben ihm,
also das hat er mir ein paar Mal so erzählt,
sie sollten irgendwelche
Bunker oder Häuser stürmen.
Und am Anfang waren sie 15
und am Ende waren sie nur noch
zwei Überlebende.
Und sein Boss
hat halt immer wieder gesagt, die sollen
quasi immer wieder neu angreifen,
bis dann halt am Ende nur noch zwei Leute übrig waren.
Und bei dem letzten Angriff
hat irgendwie mein Opa eine Granate
abbekommen, die ihm den
Fußzeh abgesprengt hat.
Und danach wurde er ins Krankenhaus
gebracht und dann heim.
Und insofern war er
lucky, dass er das überlebt hat.
Und, sag mal, eine relativ leichte
Verletzung nur davon getragen hat.
Und dementsprechend,
dementsprechend dann aus dem Krieg weg war.
Das ist aber schon krass,
wenn du jetzt überlegst.
Und man muss halt echt sagen,
der hat sich das nicht anmerken lassen.
Und als ich klein war, habe ich das
auch nicht, sozusagen, nicht wirklich
realisiert. Aber das muss schon
echt traumatisierend gewesen sein.
Man hat
das damals, gerade bei der Generation
von meinem Opa, hat man
das alles, glaube ich, noch nicht so ernst genommen.
Ja, da gibt es ja Berichte von Leuten
so nach dem Motto, die in der Kneipe gesessen haben,
es hat irgendwo die Tür geknallt, sie sind unter den Tisch
gesprungen und sowas. Da hat man so ausgelacht.
Ich glaube, das wurde
da halt auch überhaupt nicht ernst genommen.
Und er hat mir
da echt schon so ein paar Dinge erzählt,
wo ich mir auch gedacht habe, okay,
das ist nicht ohne.
Er hat auch gemeint, bei einem ihrer
Manöver,
die sie da gemacht haben
im Militär, ist neben
ihnen irgendwie Artillerie eingeschlagen.
Und
er hat es eigentlich nur knallen gehört.
Er ist nebenhin gesprungen
und
als er die Augen aufgemacht hat,
hat er gesehen, dass der Typ,
der neben ihm stand,
vorher, der stand nicht mehr neben ihm,
der hing halb durchgesplittet
über einem Baum,
über einem Baumast
im Baum.
Das hat er mir ein paar Mal erzählt
und ich glaube,
da hast du echt Dinge gesehen
im Zweiten Weltkrieg, die hast du
nie wieder vergessen. Und genau
das war damals nicht so ein Thema.
Heute ist das alles deutlich besser
untersucht und ich will nicht wissen,
wie viele Leute
damals komplett traumatisiert waren
und gar nicht mehr normal leben konnten
für Jahrzehnte,
ohne irgendwie
ansatzweise die Unterstützung bekommen
zu haben, die sie gebraucht hätten.
Die waren ja übelst...
Am Ende des Krieges
habe ich mal
in irgendeiner Doku
drüber gesehen, am Ende des Krieges
bestand die deutsche Armee zum Großteil
aus super jungen und älteren Leuten.
Also sprich alles, was bis dahin nicht am Start war.
Der Rest war
verletzt oder tot.
Du hattest ältere und super jungen.
Ja, das mit Essen
hat mir die Oma auch erzählt.
Also wir können schon echt froh sein,
dass unser einziges Problem ist,
heute auf Twitter darüber zu flamen,
ob einer im Stream irgendeinen Scheiß erzählt hat
oder nicht.
Ja, da gab es verschiedene Umschreibungen für.
Das war damals ja auch gar nicht...
Äh...
Das war dann gar nicht großartig untersucht.
Also ich finde,
es wird ein bisschen viel geflamed.
Allgemein.
Man darf nicht vergessen,
oder ich habe es schon oft gesagt im Stream,
eigentlich können wir ganz froh sein,
dass wir in der heutigen Zeit leben, in der wir leben.
Es ist sicherlich nicht alles toll.
Ja, und es gibt sicherlich noch mehr als genug,
was man verbessern kann.
Und wenn man so ein bisschen Antrieb hat
und so ein bisschen Weltverbesserer machen will,
why not?
Vielleicht kommt ja was bei raus.
Aber unterm Strich muss man sagen,
wir leben heute in der Zeit,
ich meine jetzt hier, wir,
an unserem Ort,
nicht überall in der Welt.
Es gibt ja genug, wo das noch nicht so ist.
Wir können uns persönlich so frei entfalten,
wie noch nie vorher,
ohne dass man sich irgendeinen Scheiß
von anderen Leuten anhören muss.
Leute, seriously,
wenn ich mich jetzt im Stream stellen würde,
hier und sagen,
Leute, übrigens,
by the way, ich bin schwul,
cup of pride,
da würdet ihr sagen,
ja, Max, who cares?
Ja, natürlich hast du immer noch ein paar,
die dann rumflamen würden
oder ein paar, die einen beleidigen müssten,
deswegen gibt es immer irgendwelche.
Aber zu 99% geht das den Leuten am Arsch vorbei.
Und das ist doch nice.
Heute wirst du auch nicht mehr
schepp angeguckt,
wenn du mit 35 Jahren vorm PC sitzt
und Computerspiele noch spielst.
Das ist heute, wie soll man sagen,
mainstream.
Also kannst du dich heute mehr oder weniger
so frei entfalten, wie noch nie zuvor.
Und das ist doch auch nice.
Weil wenn du jetzt,
gerade wenn du hier auf Twitter so rumscrollst,
da denkst du ja irgendwie echt,
die Welt geht unter.
Eins ist schwimmer als das andere.
Der eine Streamer streamt Hogwarts Legacy.
Oh nein, die Welt geht unter.
Ja.
Da sind die immer so am eskalieren
wegen jedem Furz, Alter.
Ich sage ja nicht,
dass es nichts zu verbessern gibt,
aber insgesamt,
aber insgesamt ist es heutzutage wirklich nice.
Zumindest hier,
in unseren breiten Graden.
Bei uns.
Ich finde es hier echt nicht verkehrt.
Twitter.
Ja, ich, ich,
also ich habe meinen Twitter umgestellt auf Andorra.
Seitdem ist es nicht mehr ganz so schlimm.
Wobei ich immer noch ab und zu
in die deutschsprachigen Trends reingucke
und mir da immer an den Kopf fassen muss,
was da für eine Scheiße teilweise trendet.
Das stimmt, da hast du recht, ja.
Das hast du recht.
Ich finde das übrigens auch blöd,
generell Leute immer mit sowas abzustempeln.
Oder gibt ja, gibt ja,
guck mal, es gibt zwei Sachen.
Es gibt die einen,
für die ist alles,
was von der anderen Seite Gutmenschen
und dann hast du die andere Seite,
für die sind alles Schlafschafe und sowas.
Ich glaube, das ist in der Realität
selten schwarz und weiß.
Und das in einer Person.
Also,
es ist selten so, dass das,
wie soll man sagen,
dass man einer Person in allen ihren Sachen
so zustimmt.
Ja, also,
viele Leute können auch
total widersprüchliche Sachen
denken.
Wo ich denke,
hey, wie passt das jetzt eigentlich zusammen?
Und,
ja, das hast du aber halt auch
dank Twitter
oder generell
dank verschiedener Blasen im Internet,
dass sich eigentlich nur
so Gleichgesinnte immer gegenseitig
Circle jerken
und sich gegenseitig
da anstacheln.
Und
nachdem die ja mehr oder weniger
permanent sich mit Gleichgesinnten
umgeben,
sind die auch der Meinung, dass die gesamte Welt
das gefälligst so zu sehen hat, wie sie.
Ja.
Und das ist auch, da gebe ich dir recht,
das ist auch eine Einstellung, die enorm
zugenommen hat.
Die meisten Leute haben
zu den meisten Themen
gar keine spezielle Meinung,
weil die es überhaupt nicht interessiert.
Das geht ihnen am Arsch vorbei.
Und wenn das Erste,
womit sie in Kontakt kommen,
irgendwelche aggressiven Twitterer sind,
die ihnen erzählen würden,
die ihnen erzählen, dass sie scheiße sind,
aus welchen Gründen auch immer,
dann sorgst du nicht dafür, dass die Leute über irgendwas nachdenken
und sich überlegen, ja, okay,
ist ja was dran, sondern du sorgst eigentlich
eher dafür, dass du noch mehr Leute
produzierst, die gegen dich sind.
Aber das kriegen sie auf Twitter
wunderbar hin.
Oder generell nicht nur, also Twitter ist halt so dieses
Bubble-Circle-Jerk-Ding,
schlechthin. Und das hast du auch
in vielen, vielen Bereichen, das stimmt.
Wenn man nicht für irgendwas ist, bist du automatisch
dagegen.
Vielen Leuten ist das meiste
vollkommen egal. Die sind mit
sich selbst beschäftigt.
Und ich glaube, viele Leute auf Twitter
wären tatsächlich auch mal ganz gut beraten,
wenn sie sich ein bisschen mehr um ihren eigenen
Scheiß kümmern würden.
Anstatt allen anderen immer zu
erzählen, wie
moralisch das, unmoralisch das
jetzt ist oder wie sie Bescheid
wissen und die anderen nicht.
Es ist alles ziemlich für den Arsch, wenn du dir das
auf Twitter... Also wenn man wirklich
Twitter ernsthaft konsumiert und sich diese ganzen
Tags anguckt und schaut, was da drunter
so abgeht und das wirklich sozusagen alles
für bare Münze nimmt und sich da reinsteigert,
da drehst du dir irgendwann am Rad.
Da wirst du verrückt.
Twitch ist teilweise auch nicht... Nee, eigentlich
so gut wie jede öffentliche Plattform ist da nicht
wirklich besser.
Das Ding ist halt, die Welt ist selten
schwarz und weiß. Es ist meistens
irgendwo so im Graubereich dazwischen.
Einzelpersonen können
übelst widersprüchliche Meinungen zu
unterschiedlichen Themen haben, wo man sich denkt,
wie passt das überhaupt zusammen?
Machst du
lieber Smalltalk oder Realtalk?
Am liebsten talk ich gar nicht mit
Leuten, weil mir die meisten Leute auf den Sack gehen.
So ein Ding, was
mir auf Social Media immer ein bisschen
auf den Keks geht, ist
nicht so sehr, dass die Leute da
ihre Meinung schreiben oder andere
flamen oder so, sondern dass sie der Meinung
sind, dass sie die
komplette, wie nennt man das so,
so diese komplette Deutungshoheit haben.
So nach dem Motto,
ich entscheide jetzt, was
richtig und falsch ist. Und sie dann
aber auch der Überzeugung sind,
die gesamte Welt muss das so sehen wie sie,
weil sie die ultimative
Entscheidungsinstanz sind, die das jetzt
entschieden haben, das was gut oder das was schlecht ist.
Und wenn du das nicht so siehst,
dann musst du nicht
einfach nur auf Twitter geflamed werden,
dann musst du nach Möglichkeit so fertig gemacht
werden, dass sich dein Arbeitgeber rausschmeißt.
Und wenn du das gut findest, dann kannst
du mit Circle Jerken in der Twitter-Bubble.
Oder umgedreht.
Je nachdem, bei welcher Seite du bist.
Das ist halt
richtig krass geworden, die letzten
Jahre über.
Es ist nicht einfach nur mehr Meinungsverschiedenheit,
es ist sehr viel Zerstörungswut
auf beiden Seiten. Oder was heißt
auf beiden? Es gibt nicht nur zwei Seiten,
auf allen Seiten dabei.
Sehr viel Zerstörungswut. Es geht nicht
darum, den anderen zu erzählen, dass sie
falsch liegen, es geht darum, den anderen
zu erzählen, dass sie quasi
falsch liegen und dadurch
quasi nahezu unmenschlich sind
und man sie fertig machen kann bis aufs Blut.
Das ist Social Media
auf Twitter in vielen Fällen.
Und das ist halt echt
was, wo ich mir denke, das
artet immer mehr aus.
Das hast du bei
verschiedenen Sachen gesehen die letzten Jahre über
ich denke die Hogwarts Legacy Sache
war ein gutes Beispiel für
das hat sich ja Wochen und
Monate fast hingezogen.
Und da wurde sich das Todes geflamed.
Es wurde sich angezeigt gegenseitig.
Es wurde versucht
das Leben von Leuten zu ruinieren
mit Anrufen bei Arbeitgebern.
Und ey, das ist
nicht mehr normal, Leute, was da abgeht.
Naja.
Warum nicht?
Letztendlich ist, egal was du gewählt hast, fast alles
Kacke. Ja, ich hab tatsächlich
die FDP gewählt das letzte Mal.
Das ist aber auch kein Geheimnis, weil
das hab ich das letzte Mal ja auch schon erzählt im Stream.
Aber wir wissen noch, der Markt regelt sich.
Er regelt das schon.
Ich würde noch nicht mal sagen, dass es jeder tut.
Aber die, die es tun, machen das
in einer enorm penetranten Art und Weise.
Wisst ihr, und das ist das
letzte, was ich dazu sagen will.
Ich hab, ähm,
wie in Frieden...
Ne, das nächste Mal wähl ich nicht FDP.
Weil die wahrscheinlich nicht über 5% packen.
Wie gesagt, ich finde Social Media
an sich und das
anderer Meinung sein, ist eigentlich was, wo ich
unterm Strich sagen würde, bringt die Leute voran.
Bringt die Sache vorwärts. Aber es geht
ja nicht darum, anderer Meinung zu sein,
um vielleicht da drüber zu diskutieren
oder sich ein bisschen zu flamen oder sowas.
Ich finde die Zerstörungswut gegenseitig
ist einfach viel zu groß da mittlerweile.
Ich werd der Musik im Hintergrund los.
Wupp, wupp, wupp, wupp, wupp, wupp.
Alles klar.
Also ich hab keine Ahnung.
Es ist glücklicherweise auch noch ein bisschen hin.
Bis zur,
bis zur nächsten Wahl.
Ich, mal ein Beispiel.
Okay, wir machen mal, wir machen mal
ein Beispiel dazu.
Wo, wo du Twitter
komplett mit auf die Palme bringen
könntest. Stellt euch mal
vor, das ist jetzt,
stellt euch mal vor, ich würde theoretisch
posten auf Twitter.
Angenommen, es wäre jetzt
Bundestagswahl, ja. Und ich würde,
ich würde auf Twitter sowas posten wie
Leute, geht wählen.
Das ist richtig. Wählt
was ihr wollt.
Selbst wenn es die AfD ist.
Stellt euch mal vor, ich würde das jetzt twittern.
Dann würde auf der einen Seite
komplett eskaliert werden.
Wie kann das sein? Die würden dann rein
interpretieren, Max empfiehlt, Leute in der AfD zu wählen.
Die würden komplett, die würden komplett
triggert, die würden komplett eskalieren.
Ja.
Aber, die andere Seite,
die andere Seite, würde auch
komplett eskalieren.
So nach dem Motto, guckt mal
hier, der Max
dreht das so, dass er sich dem Mainstream
schon so anbiedert. Das würden
alle, es würden alle beide Seiten
voll eskalieren.
Das heißt, du hast eigentlich gar keine
Chance, wenn du da irgendwas sagst in der
Richtung.
Alle beiden Seiten würden
voll ausrasten.
Livestreams Fails ist informiert,
ja. Die würden alle ausrasten.
Ja.
Das ist super, ist super getriggert.
Alle wieder, wenn du sowas posten
würdest. Und nein, den
anderen, dem würde das auch nicht gefallen.
Weil, die pro-AfD-Leute
würden diese, würde diese,
wie soll man sagen,
dieses, ähm,
würde meinen Post
überhaupt nicht gefallen.
Weil das für die viel zu hinten rum wäre.
Die würden dann sagen, ja, guck mal,
der Max würde das ja gerne machen, aber
er traut sich nicht, das öffentlich zu sagen.
Also eigentlich, ne,
macht er das ja schlecht.
Da würden sich, es würden sich beide Seiten
ultra getriggert fühlen.
Oder noch,
machen wir es anders. Ich müsste, ich müsste den
Twitter-Post anders formulieren.
Ich müsste den Twitter-Post anders formulieren.
Dann, dann würden, dann würden sich definitiv
beide Seiten getriggert fühlen.
Ich müsste schreiben, morgen ist
Bundestagswahl, äh, geht
alle wählen, das ist wichtig.
Wählt, was ihr wollt,
selbst wenn's die AfD ist.
Ähm,
obwohl
das für mich nix wäre.
So müsste ich das schreiben. Und das würde
beide Seiten das Todestriggern.
Die einen würden
sagen, oh hier, hier,
ist die Kram, alles hier voll, empfiehlt die AfD.
Und die anderen würden sagen, guck mal
hier, wie verklausuliert er das
wieder schreibt, und eigentlich
will er sich dann nur anbiedern,
der anderen Seite, und das schlecht machen.
Das würde beides sein. Brutals triggern.
Und das ist halt
das Ding so auf Twitter.
Deswegen ist das Beste, was man machen kann,
bei solchen Sachen gar nix dazu
sagen. Was ja übrigens auch laut
Umfragen,
ähm,
im Trend liegt, ja.
Wenn man sich Umfragen
anguckt, dann
sagt ein nicht, und ich weiß nicht, wie viel's genau sind,
deswegen sag ich jetzt keine Prozentzahl, ein nicht unerheblicher
Teil der Leute,
sagt, sie
haben das Gefühl, öffentlich
nicht das, was sie
denken, sagen zu können.
Was sicherlich auch ein bisschen mit diesem
Fertiggemache von allen Seiten
egal, was du sagst,
liegt.
Naja.
Aber ich werde das auch nicht posten auf Twitter
in der nächsten Bundestagswahl.
Das war jetzt nur ein Beispiel, ja.
Und es würde beides sein, ultra triggern.
So.
Das würde auch beides, das würde auch
Leute ultra triggern.
Wisst ihr, was man daran
sieht ist, dass das würde beide Seiten
gleichermaßen triggern.
Das ist halt so das Widersprüchliche.
Dabei postest
du von der Aussage her
noch was relativ Normales.
Geht wählen, ja.
Den Rest muss man
weglassen.
Aber das war jetzt ja nur ein Beispiel für,
wie man eine Sache posten kann,
was die komplett entgegengesetzten
Lager triggern würde.
Aber denkst du, es ändert was, wenn du die Grünen sagst?
Wenn ich das genauso
schreiben würde,
ja, nee, das würde wahrscheinlich
nicht viel ändern.
Wahrscheinlich würde das nicht
viel ändern.
Wenn ich schreiben würde auf Twitter,
Leute, morgen ist Bundestagswahl,
geht wählen, es ist wichtig.
Geht wählen, was ihr wollt, selbst wenn
es die Grünen sind, auch wenn das nicht so
mein Ding ist.
Das würde wahrscheinlich
wenig ändern.
Das würde wahrscheinlich auch beide Seiten ultra triggern.
Wahrscheinlich ist es sogar fast egal.
Ja,
wahrscheinlich würde das schon reichen.
Ich bin übrigens mal sehr gespannt,
wann ist Bundestagswahl?
2025?
Ende des Jahres,
irgendwann 2025.
Ich bin sehr gespannt,
was da rauskommt.
Oh nein,
ich habe echt keine Ahnung,
wen ich wählen werde.
Die FDP werde ich nicht mehr wählen,
weil ich nicht glaube,
dass es die FDP,
zumindest wenn es so weitergeht,
irgendwie noch über 5% kommt.
4%?
Nee, 5%, oder?
Die werden das wahrscheinlich nicht schaffen.
Dementsprechend kein Plan.
Jetzt geht es hier schon im Chat.
So,
wir gucken mal, was so trendet
auf GitHub.
Ach ja, wisst ihr, wo ich auch sehr gespannt drauf bin?
Was
nächstes Jahr rauskommt,
nee, nicht nächstes Jahr,
Ende dieses Jahres,
in den USA, was da rauskommt.
Da bin ich mal sehr gespannt.
Da haben sie ja die Auswahl zwischen
dem einen Opa und dem anderen Opa.
Die sind ja witzigerweise
gar nicht so unterschiedlich alt.
Ich glaube,
Trump ist doch auch irgendwie
nur 4 oder 5 Jahre oder so jünger
als die beiden.
Die sind beide viel zu alt eigentlich.
Oder fragst du normalerweise,
sitzt du da als Rentner irgendwo,
guckst du am Fenster und meckerst
über die Leute, die Fußball spielen
im Garten?
Das ist eine schöne Aussage und weißt du was?
Selbst wenn du das auf Twitter postest,
wären alle
ultra getriggert.
Weil du
die
ihrer Meinung nach
Bösen nicht ausgeschlossen hast
in deinem Post. Da werden auch beide Seiten getriggert.
Da werden auch alle sein.
Deswegen, es ist auf Twitter enorm schwierig.
Du kannst dich eigentlich nicht zu diesem Thema
äußern, ohne dass du
irgendeine Seite triggerst.
Und es gibt nicht nur zwei Seiten,
es gibt nahezu unendlich viele.
Und es ist auch sehr widersprüchlich,
was die gleichen Leute posten.
Also was bei den Amis rauskommt, bin ich auch mal sehr gespannt.
Vielleicht kriegen wir dann
wieder solche lustigen Sachen wie
zu Corona muss man
Desinfektionsmittel trinken und sowas.
Ich mein für den
Entertainment Faktor war das schon nicht schlecht.
Muss man zugeben.
Also ich fand den Entertainment Faktor
von außen betrachtet
zur Trump Zeit
deutlich nicer als jetzt.
Das einzig witzige, was es
was ich bisher mitbekommen hab
von beiden ist, diese Zusammenschnitte
die es auf YouTube gibt, wo er seinen Text vergisst
bei irgendwelchen Reden.
Oder wo er
was letztens den Präsident
verwechselt hat von Venezuela und
Mexiko oder irgendwie sowas.
Aber das muss ich sagen, der Entertainment Faktor
war bei Trump schon höher.
Oder Mexiko und Ägypten.
Der Entertainment Faktor war schon höher.
Ja so genau bin ich da nicht drin bei den Amis
was da abgeht.
So dann lass uns doch mal gucken
was auf GitHub so trendet.
Ok also. Achja.
Das sind die die Nintendo verklagt hat.
Oder verklagen will.
Verklagt hat.
Die haben anscheinend einiges an Zuspruch
bekommen diese Woche.
Viele Leute. Das ist halt das Ding
bei solchen Sachen Nintendo.
Auch viele Leute
die Yuzu nicht kennen
wurden jetzt durch die News
zufällig darauf aufmerksam.
Da gibt es hier einen Nintendo Switch
Emulator.
Leute ist ja gut im Chat jetzt.
Man kann sich
ich gebe euch nochmal einen Tipp Chat.
Damit das Ganze jetzt nicht ausartet.
Man kann sich auch darauf verständigen
dass man einfach unterschiedlicher
Meinung ist bei irgendeinem Thema und dann ist gut.
Erstmal ein Mirror ziehen.
Ich glaube nicht, dass
das gelöscht wird. Außerdem gibt es
so viele Kopien davon.
Lässiger Lord. Danke für den Sub.
Ich glaube nicht, dass
das ein Problem ist.
Ich kann mir auch nicht vorstellen, dass
Nintendo damit Erfolg hat.
Michael 5 Milliarden du hast ja gestern
subscribt. Habe ich gar nicht mitbekommen.
Schön für den Sub. Nice.
Nice.
Okay das ist
AI. Über AI überspringen wir.
AI.
Ein C++
Interface für irgendwas. Allein schon weil es
C++ ist. Gucken wir uns das in die Nähe an.
Ähm
Absolut keine Ahnung
was das sein soll.
China-Chinesen-Kram auf jeden Fall.
China
Ai Sun.
Ah ja.
Okay alles klar.
Ich habe seriously absolut keinen
blassen Schimmer was das sein soll.
China-Chinesen-Zeug.
Ist ein riesiger
Leak an chinesischen Hackertools.
Aha. Chinese Hackermans.
Das habe ich mir schon mal angeschaut.
Das war glaube ich ganz nice.
Microsoft Activation Scripts.
Ah.
Alles klar.
Was das ist?
Das ist
Web App for watching movies easily.
Ich vermute mal, dass es
ein Web Interface ist, wo du verschiedene Plugins
hast, über welche Wege
du Movies gucken kannst. Hier.
From Third Party
Providers.
Diese Third Party Providers müssen nicht
zwangsläufig legal sein, also nein.
Die Third Party Providers sind wahrscheinlich
legal, aber die Quellen, woher
diese Sachen gezogen werden, die müssen nicht
zwangsläufig legal sein.
Die Activation Scripts nutzt Microsoft selber.
Ja, das ist gut.
Mario Kart 3 GS. Da habe ich ein Video zu gesehen.
Irgendjemand hat Mario Kart in
JavaScript gebaut.
Es ist ein bisschen milchig alles, oder?
Und die Controls sind weird.
Und da hat die Strecken...
Okay, ohne jegliche Animation.
Ein bisschen sehr
blurry ist hier alles.
Chat, ich habe Mario Kart schon eine ganze Weile
nicht mehr gespielt. Ist das eine offiziell
importierte Strecke?
Oder hat er die gebaut?
Dark Reader, meinst du, ist das?
Ich habe hier gar kein
Dark Reader an.
In Chrome.
Wenn das Mario Kart Tour ist, dann hat er die Strecke
etwa aus
Android extrahiert, oder
hat er die nachgebaut?
Wie gesagt, ich habe weder Mario Kart Tour
noch in letzter Zeit Mario Kart gespielt.
Zumindest hat er nur die
Geometrie-Sachen importiert und keine
Animationen und so. Aber es ist schon cool,
dass sowas mit JavaScript funzt, oder?
Ich würde gerne mein Item einsetzen,
wenn ich wüsste, wie...
Wow, keine...
Oh, Leute.
Die Collision ist kaputt.
Okay, da sind wir wieder.
Ah, so löst
mein Item sein, okay.
Ich weiß nicht, wo die Strecke lang
geht, ehrlich gesagt. Außen?
Hier irgendwo? Ne.
Schätke, wo geht die Strecke lang?
Hier nicht.
Wann kommt die Klage von Nintendo?
Ne, allein schon,
allein schon, dass dort
irgendwie Mario importiert wurde, ist
Anzeige ist raus.
Ich hab seriously keine Ahnung, wo es lang geht.
Guck mal, der hat sogar
die Turbo Mechanic drin.
Ich meine, die Steuerung, die Steuerung
ist schon mies, ja, im Vergleich zum Original.
Aber für,
für JavaScript, und guck mal auch, wie
flüssig und nice das im Browser läuft.
Ich glaube, das ist alles,
was von der Strecke verfügbar ist, kann das sein?
Ne.
Naja. Mario Kart CS.
Aber cool, dass sowas in JavaScript mittlerweile
tut. Hab ich eigentlich den
Streamtitel ordentlich geändert? Aufwachen
Stream, ja. So, was haben wir denn sonst
noch hier?
AI? AI?
Äh, wahrscheinlich auch AI?
Java-Kram?
React-Zeug?
Okay, ich verstehe null,
was das sein soll.
Ein intuitives Squee
für Glee, Glee-Gen?
That uses Comfy UI in the back.
What?
Gen klingt schon mal irgendwie nach AI.
AI-Zeug auf jeden Fall.
Das ist cool.
Hier hab ich auch schon die ein oder anderen Sachen
drinne gefunden. Public, also List of
public UIs.
Da hab ich Geocoding-Sachen mal
drinne gefunden, ja.
Reverse Geocoding.
Und ich hab irgendeinen Service benutzt, der
P. Irgendwas mit
Proton oder so hieß. Ne.
Äh.
Ja.
Also damit kann man beispielsweise
Straßen zu
Koordinaten
auflösen und Koordinaten zu
Straßen und sowas.
Also ich kann quasi sagen,
wo befinde ich mich an dieser Koordinat
und dann sagt der mir, ah, sie befinden sich
Frankfurt
in Zeil 5 oder so.
Da hab ich irgendeinen Service benutzt,
der nannte sich Photon oder so, glaub ich.
Hab ich auch hier
glaub sogar aus dieser Liste gefunden.
Äh, AI.
AI.
AI. AI.
Nicht AI.
AI. AI. AI.
Okay, diese Woche ist ja gefühlt
90% AI.
Okay, lass mal kurz gucken, was in
Was uns die Sharp trendet. Wahrscheinlich
so ganz oben.
Diese Woche.
Was? Okay.
Noch ein anderer Nintendo
Switch Emulator trendet.
AI.
ASP.NET Core trendet.
Zurecht. Bestes Webframework.
Backendtechnisch ever.
Gehört Blazor
eigentlich offiziell zu ASP.NET Core?
Bin ja kein großer
Blazor-Fan. Maui, dass das trendet,
versteh ich nicht.
Und, und das ist noch
zu viel. Ich mag
Maui überhaupt nicht.
China-Chinesen.net Guide.
Jellyfin.
Der Billy Billy
Downloader. Billy Billy ist das China
YouTube, gell?
Okay, wenn man will, dass seine Blazor-Seiten
hässlich aussehen, dann kann man
das verwenden.
Leute, ich hab keinen Darkreader. Alter.
Wenn man will,
dass seine Webseite aussieht, dann kann man das verwenden.
Wie die hässliche Microsoft Documentation
Seite, dann kann man das verwenden.
Boah, ist das eklig,
alter.
Wollt ihr wirklich, dass eure Webseite
so aussieht? Seriously?
Hab ich jetzt Darkreader an oder aus?
Okay.
Es sieht ja noch hässlicher aus.
Ne, jetzt hab ich's. Moment.
Jetzt ist es an, jetzt ist es aus.
Bin mal ernsthaft, dass seine Webseite so aussieht, ja?
Ich find, das sieht mies aus.
Gibt es, kann man noch Light Theme machen?
Light?
Okay, Light sieht
nur halbwegs brauchbar aus.
Haben die sowas wie ein
Date Picker oder sowas?
Picker?
Naja.
Aber hier ist was Date Time.
Okay, Leute, ich geb zu.
Es sieht nicht richtig scheiße aus.
Aber ich find nicht, dass
es gut aussieht.
Ich mag die, das Feeling davon nicht.
Wie benutzt man das? Ist das ein
Das ist, das ist ein
Ja, das ist reines, reines
Blazer Gedöns.
Okay, jetzt muss ich mal gucken, wie machen die
Wie machen die die
Progress Bar? Das ist natürlich schon ganz
interessant.
Ob die nen Progress nehmen oder
nen selbstgestyltes Element.
Sie nehmen selbstgestyltes
Element, ja?
Was ich sehr gut finde.
Ja, ja, ja.
Es ist kein, es ist kein
weiterer Progress Bar.
Was besser, was, was, was
auch nicht so gut wäre.
Also dann machen die es richtig.
Also mir gefällt das Feeling hiervon gar nicht.
Es sieht aus wie die Microsoft
Documentation Seite und mit der verbinde ich
nichts Gutes.
Einmal nen Input, Form und Inputs.
Time Picker, ah den haben wir schon.
Switch, gut so wie es sein muss.
Gibt es einen Pin Input?
Äh, das ist mir zu
Windows mäßig hier das ganze.
Ne, da habe ich keinen
Bock drauf.
Was für nen Ding?
RPG Framework.
Ah, für
Weeb Games.
Ne, naja,
bisschen, vielleicht.
Welcher UI Style ist gerade
in? Also,
was man oft sieht, leider
ist Material Design Style,
der mir persönlich gar nicht gefällt.
...
Material Design Style sieht man
dank Google und Android relativ oft.
Ansonsten,
welcher Chat, da seid ihr vielleicht die ganzen
Web Entwicklungsleute
hier und Web Designer Leute.
Welcher UI Style ist gerade angesagt?
Also, meinem Eindruck nach
gibt es immer noch viel zu viel Material Design.
Und ein paar, die gerne aussehen
wollen wie Apple.
Manch einer hat auch noch Bootstrap, was einfach aussieht
wie Bootstrap.
Welcher Style ist gerade so
im Trend?
Ich kann es euch nicht sagen.
Ich bin ja auch nicht der Designmeister, was
Webseiten angeht.
Ich kann auch nur sagen, was ich höre.
Habt ihr Beispiele für Material Design?
Ja, habe ich.
Für schlechtes Material Design.
Da muss ich immer den Date Picker nehmen.
Ich finde das so abartig.
Und mit der 24 Stunden Uhr
ist noch schlimmer. Guckt euch das mal an, Alter.
Meine Güte, ey.
Ich finde das so.
Das ist der Design Horror schlechthin.
Dieser Date, dieser Time Picker,
dieser Standard Material Design Time Picker.
Du findest das clever? Ernsthaft?
Ich finde das richtig eklig.
Das ist so ein typisches Ding für
es funktioniert
auf Mobile halbwegs,
aber auf dem Desktop ist es einfach kacke.
Das ist richtig widerlich, ja.
Das ist Material Design.
Das ist eines meiner Lieblings Negativbeispiele,
warum Material Design suckt.
Ansonsten,
was Material Design ausmacht,
sind oftmals diese
so runden Buttons
mit sehr kontrastreichen Farben,
die man aus Android-Anwendungen kennt.
Wisst ihr diese,
schwer zu sagen,
viele Android-Anwendungen
haben unten rechts einen sehr kontrastreichen
runden Button.
Material Design Components.
Ist das das Neue?
Das sieht ja sogar schon
in der Vorschau grausam aus.
Und es ist alles sehr rund
bei Material Design.
Was ist hier los?
Warum sieht das so kacke aus?
M2, gibt es M2 hier auch noch?
Not found.
Ja, das hier
und dieses Hamburger Menü.
Floating Action Button, genau.
Das hier oben, das ist typisches
Material Design Optik.
Das Hamburger Menü,
das so genauso.
Das ist dieses typische Android Material Design.
Diese stark kontrastreiche Buttons
und
App-Bar.
Das Hamburger Menü oben links.
Das animierte Ein- und Ausfaden,
wenn man da drauf klickt.
Das Sucher-Icon.
Das ist so diese typische Material Design Optik.
Und ich mag,
ich kann der Sache gar nichts abgewinnen.
Ja, und solche Pop-Ups und so.
Genau so
sieht das halt aus.
Das ist die typische Material Design Optik.
Mit der App,
mit diesem Dialog
und diesen kontrastreichen Buttons
und dem Floating Button unten rechts.
Maxi wäre eine IP-Eingabe
mit dem Date-Time Picker.
Du meinst, dass du dann auswählen kannst
von 0 bis 255
und das ganze vier Mal?
Das wäre wahrscheinlich genauso eklig.
Das Ding ist halt,
das ist schön und gut, wenn man das
auf Mobile machen muss.
Aber auf dem Desktop kann man auch
einfach was tippen.
Also schneller als in irgendeinem Menü
250 verschiedene Optionen auszuwählen.
Welches Design gefällt dir?
Gibt es da was?
Ja, immer wieder.
Aber schwer zu sagen.
Obviously,
pick das Twitter-Design gefällt mir.
Weil es was eigenes ist
und gut zur
Video, zu einer Videoplattform
passt.
Ich würde zwar ein paar Sachen ändern
auf Twitter, wenn ich könnte.
Aber alles in allem finde ich
das Twitter-Design echt nice.
Nicht Twitter, Twitch.
Hört nicht auf mich,
was ich sage.
Ich meine, ersetzt alles, was ich gesagt habe,
Twitter durch Twitch.
Twitch-Design finde ich nice, nicht Twitter.
Als Videoplattform
finde ich, passt das auch
mit den Animationen,
die sie haben, wenn du
den Chat anklickst, die Videos anklickst
und dann das Videofenster oben bleibt.
Ich finde, Twitch ist ganz gut gemacht.
Twitter ist auch ganz brauchbar.
Ich persönlich,
aber da bin ich wahrscheinlich einer
der wenigen,
die das noch gut finden.
Wisst ihr, welches
grundsätzliche,
nicht das Design, aber welchen
grundsätzlichen Aufbau ich mag
bei Webseiten auf dem Desktop?
Das sind Webseiten, die
sich wie auf dem Desktop anfühlen.
Zum Beispiel,
Hacker News hat kein, ich sag gleich dabei,
Hacker News hat kein schönes Design.
Aber,
ich finde das für eine Desktop-Anwendung
besser
als tausendfaches,
wobei,
ne, ich zieh's zurück,
die haben auch sowas ähnliches wie
Endlos-Scrollen mittlerweile, nur dass es
nicht endlos scrollt.
Es ist auch schon ein bisschen vermobilisiert,
aber immerhin.
Das finde ich vom Ansatz her nicht schlecht,
dass man sagt, ey, guck mal,
wir haben heutzutage Desktop-Rechner
mit 64 GB RAM,
fetten CPUs und alles,
wir können mehr als fünf Zeilen Text rendern
auf einer Webseite.
Ich mag das, wenn Webseiten sich auf dem Desktop
anfühlen wie Desktop-Anwendungen.
Oder wie eben Desktop-Webseiten.
Old Reddit ist auch nicht schön.
Machen wir hier Reddit Frankfurt.
Wo bestimmt gleich mal
jemand fragen muss, ist es safe
on off zu gehen?
Ich habe einen Biber gesehen.
Nice.
Also Old Reddit ist auch nicht schön.
Server-Side-Processing?
Nö, nö, nö, nicht unbedingt.
Ich mag Single-Page-Applications,
zumindest zum Selbstprogrammieren.
Und allgemein finde ich
es nicht verkehrt, Sachen kleinseitig
zu machen.
Endlos-Scroll und die Sachen
optisch überall
gleich anzupassen für Mobile
hat ja nichts mit kleinseitig zu tun
oder nicht.
Also das alte Reddit fand ich auch
ganz brauchbar, wenn ich da auch einiges
ändern würde, wenn ich könnte.
Aber ich mag Webseiten, die sich halt
nach Webseiten anfühlen
und nicht nach Mobile-App.
Und ansonsten muss ich sagen,
Bootstrap könnte echt schlimmer sein.
Vor ein paar Jahren
Hatten die nicht so eine
Vorsicht.
Get Bootstrapped.
Vor ein paar Jahren
hätte ich ja gesagt, Alter,
bleibt mir weg.
Bleibt mir weg mit Bootstrap.
Aber ich muss sagen, ich finde die Bootstrap
Optik
gar nicht so schlecht mittlerweile.
Ja.
Das geht, ich finde das geht voll klar.
Bootstrap.
Was ich vor ein paar Jahren an Bootstrap
nicht mochte ist, dass im Prinzip
jede Seite
nach Bootstrap ausgesehen hat.
Aber mittlerweile ist es nicht
mal ganz so krass verbreitet.
Das sind halt die typischen Bootstrap Buttons.
Ich finde Bootstrap gar nicht mehr so schlecht
und so schlimm mittlerweile.
Das geht schon
klar.
Bootstrap.
Ich finde das geht echt klar.
Also was ich auf
im Frontend benutze als
Frontend Framework ist in letzter Zeit
immer Svelte.
Beziehungsweise jetzt in letzter Zeit
habe ich mir das Ganze auch mit Svelte 5 angeguckt.
Aber
ich kann mich noch nicht so richtig festlegen
auf irgendein UI Framework.
Ich bastel
viel selbst, was
immer Paintschamp ist, weil ich nicht der
große Designchamp
bin. Ich weiß noch, wo wir mal
45 Minuten einen Input gestylt haben
und es sah immer noch kacke aus.
Könnt ihr euch vielleicht noch
daran erinnern? Letztens, wo ich
versucht habe irgendwie so einen
Dropdown
mit Input
zum Suchen zu stylen.
Das ist ewig gedauert.
Nein, das heißt Svelte.
Das heißt nicht Svelte.
Moment.
Ich kann dir beweisen, dass das
wirklich Svelte heißt.
Das ist der Erfinder
von Svelte.
Und jetzt passt mal auf,
wie er Svelte ausspricht.
Ist die leise das Ganze, hä?
Warum? Aha.
Wegen Mario Kart ist das so leise.
Hast du gehört? Was hat er gesagt?
Svelte 5.
Und ich Svelte.
Das habe ich auch schon ausprobiert. Ich habe auch schon
Skeleton UI ausprobiert.
Und das letzte, womit ich ein bisschen rumgespielt
war schätzen.
Svelte.
Wie auch immer man das richtig ausspricht.
Das war das letzte, womit ich ein bisschen rumgebastelt habe.
UI Framework technisch.
Und das fand ich vom Ansatz her
bisher das Beste.
Nicht wirklich von der Optik
oder von der Vielfalt an Komponenten.
Den Ansatz fand ich wirklich nice.
Und zwar, dass es kein
UI Framework im klassischen Sinne ist,
wo du fertige Komponenten kriegst, sondern
dass du,
also auch wenn es Komponenten heißt,
sondern, dass du
im Endeffekt
Source Code bekommst
der Komponenten
in dein Projekt
und von da selbst weitermachen kannst.
Du bekommst quasi Base Komponenten, den kompletten Source Code
und kannst es dann customizen, wie du willst.
Fand ich vom Ansatz her
bisher
das von allem, was ich ausprobiert habe, am angenehmsten.
Dafür ist es
nicht so vielfältig, wie manch andere
Frameworks.
Ich habe zum Rennen gefrühstückt.
Das heißt, ich habe jetzt schon wieder Hunger,
weil ich bin ja die Sache wieder
los geworden jetzt.
Lass mich mal kurz checken,
wie viel Kalorien habe ich laut Garmin verbraucht.
Lass mal kurz gucken,
was mein Garmin Ding meint.
Alter, kann mal bitte der
Widescreen Mode ausgehen.
Ich habe verbraucht Kalorien
882 Kalorien, sagt er.
10 Kilometer
1 Stunde 4
Wie gesagt,
das war nicht sonderlich schnell, aber anstrengend.
Genau das Gegenteil gefühlt
von letzter Woche.
Okay, gucken wir mal.
Die Bild hat geschrieben, US-Firmen
warnen vor was? Drogenstraßen
in Deutschland. Da war Frankfurt gemeint.
Weil da ein Straßenplan mit
Gefährdungsindikator gezeigt wurde.
Naja, Nidderstraße
und Taunusstraße
und so die Ecke da vorne ist halt
berühmt, berüchtigt.
Ja, in Frankfurt.
Mich hat
Vue bei dem Umstieg von 2 auf 3
verloren.
Aber da war ich wahrscheinlich noch
zu Frontend Noob.
Weil Svelte
3 oder 4
zu 5 jetzt
vollzieht ja sagen wir mal
einen nicht ganz
unähnlichen Wandel
von Vue 2 zu Vue 3.
Zumindest
von den möglichen
Styles, wie man
das benutzen kann.
Mit ähm
Signals und
Runes nennt das Svelte jetzt.
Es ist recht ähnlich zu dem, was Vue 3 gemacht hat.
Aber ich war damals einfach nicht ready
dafür. Da war ich noch zu Frontend Noob.
Mittlerweile muss ich sagen,
ich find den Ansatz von Svelte 5 richtig.
Und auch besser.
Weniger Magic.
Umso weniger Magic, umso besser.
Die Leute sind natürlich ein bisschen am Flamen
und sagen Svelte 5 ist jetzt quasi wie React.
Es kann allein schon nicht.
Was ich darauf antworten will, es kann allein schon nicht
wie React sein, weil du keinen JSX programmieren musst.
Oder keinen JSX benutzen musst.
JSX ist ja das
der größte Faktor, der mich persönlich
an React abschreckt.
Ansonsten muss man ja klar
sagen, React ist mit Abstand
das größte Frontend
Framework. Aber JSX
schreckt mich irgendwie, also mich schreckt
generell HTML
und CSS in
JavaScript ab.
Was sagt ihr dazu?
Ich hab ein paar Frontend-Five jetzt
in meinem Chat.
JSX POG or not POG?
Oder allgemein HTML in JavaScript
anstatt HTML in HTML.
Alles wird
wie React mit der Zeit.
Das könnte man auch anders
interpretieren. Und zwar, dass React
von Anfang an vieles richtig gemacht hat.
Aber auch nicht alles,
weil es wird nicht alles wie React.
JSX lassen
die meisten Frameworks glücklicherweise
außen vor.
Also es wird vielleicht ein bisschen mehr
wie React in den Punkten, was React gut gemacht hat.
Okay Chatge, was gucken
wir uns denn jetzt an? Was haben wir denn hier?
Wifi 7 getestet. Okay, was sollen
wir uns zuerst angucken?
Wifi 7 oder
kein Pador für Parkshünder,
der Anzeigen-Hauptmeister. Und ich guck
mir das nur an, weil der Chat gemeint hat, Max,
das musst du unbedingt sehen.
Der Anzeigen-Hauptmeister, okay.
CSS in JSX ist mit Tailwind
kein Problem. Ist das nicht
immer noch so, dass du in JSX nicht klar
schreiben kannst, sondern Class Name?
Weil Class ein Received, äh,
nicht Received, ähm,
Restricted?
Nee.
Ein Keyword von
JavaScript ist ein Restricted
Keyword.
Niedu, dankeschön für den Sub.
Excellent.
Was? Heute
passend zu deinem Vater.
Echt? Warum?
Dating und Partnersuche.
So arbeitet eine Partnervermittlerin.
Oh ja, stimmt, hast recht, das passt
zu meinem Vater, ja.
Weiß nicht, ob die auch die Leute scammt
wie mein Vater? Eigentlich eher nicht.
Ich auch.
Ich auch. Deswegen haben
die mich auch bei Vue 3 damit ein bisschen
verloren. Da war ich einfach
nicht ready für.
Du kannst das nicht schon wiedersehen.
Ist das Cringe? Ich hab keinen Bock
auf Cringe-Videos jetzt.
Ich hab keinen Bock auf Cringe-Videos.
Es kommt...
Oh MonkaS, ich hab zu viel offener.
Ist Cringe?
Ich bin nicht ready für Cringe-Videos
jetzt.
Ich weiß, dass man das machen kann, aber dadurch, dass
die...
Ich weiß, dass man die Options-API noch verwenden kann, aber
dadurch, dass die die anderen
Weisen so gepusht haben, hat man sich als
sollte eigentlich nicht mehr verwendet
werden gefühlt in Vue 3.
Okay.
Okay. Schau mal. Okay, wir gucken jetzt,
wir gucken uns das jetzt an. Das geht ja schnell.
Niklas Matai
ist 18 Jahre alt und hat
ein bizarres Hobby. Weil er
leidenschaftlich gerne Falschparker jagt,
nennt er sich...
Weil er sonst nichts zu tun hat.
...Anzeigenhauptmeister. Heute ist er im
Sachsen-Anhaltischen Gräfenhainichen
auf Streife. Darf der überhaupt
Polizei hinten drauf stehen haben?
Wenn der nicht Polizist ist?
Vor Niklas ist kein Parksünder sicher.
Es ist Samstag und in der gerade
fußgängerlosen Fußgängerzone
wird ein Fahrzeug ausgemacht.
Was? Da steht nicht Polizei?
Da steht Pol...
Achso, da steht nicht Polizei.
Okay. Ja, dann ist...
Dann darf er das
wahrscheinlich.
Vor Niklas ist
kein Parksünder sicher.
Es ist Samstag und in der gerade
fußgängerlosen Fußgängerzone
wird ein Fahrzeug als Hindernis ausgemacht.
Das Fahrzeug parkt in der Fußgängerzone
und behindert dadurch andere
Verkehrsteilnehmer.
Wen behindert das jetzt hier?
Wir wurden gerade behindert. Wir sind ja da rechts hier
gelaufen und mussten jetzt einen Schlenker nach links machen.
Warum machen Sie das?
Okay. Das triggert mich aber auch,
dass der Typ vorm Hoftor steht.
Mich triggert nicht so sehr, dass der da steht,
aber mich triggert, dass der vorm
Hoftor steht.
Was ist Ihre Motivation?
Um die Straßenverkehrsordnung durchzusetzen,
weil die Leute da sind.
Die Leute denken, die können parken, wie sie wollen,
gerade jetzt zum Wochenende.
Ja, who cares, Mann.
Der Verstoß kostet 70 Euro.
Ich parke auch nicht vor
meinem Tor.
Ich parke auch nicht vor meinem Tor.
Für eine spezielle Falschparker-App
bringt der Hilfs-Sheriff
das Delikt zur Anzeige.
Anzeige ist raus.
In dem Fall
OAV 327-24.
Moment. Das geht mittlerweile
alles online.
Farbe, Silber.
Standort wird automatisch erfasst.
Und dann
Vergehen.
Schwierigkeit aus Fußgängerzone kann ich eingeben.
Dieser Verstoß.
Aber man muss schon sagen,
also nice da zu stehen ist es nicht,
falls da einer mit Kinderwagen durch will und sowas.
Auf der anderen Seite ist es Sonntagmorgen
und da ist halt nichts los.
Ich denke, es ist klar,
dass der da nichts zu stehen hat.
Im Bereich einer Fußgängerzone.
Es ist aber viel zu blöd rumzulaufen
und überall zu fotografieren.
Aber gut, jeder hat seine Hobbys.
Dadurch Zeichen 230, 240, 241
oder 242.1
gesperrt worden.
Behinderten dadurch andere.
Der weiß Bescheid.
12 vor 54 festgestellt.
Die Anzeige geht um 13 Uhr raus.
Also gebe ich 13 Uhr ein.
Das Timing stimmt.
Die Anzeige ist gerade raus.
Da kommt der Fahrer.
Die Frau ist in Urlaub.
In Boston.
Ich bin da weg.
Das finde ich jetzt schon ein bisschen unangenehm,
die Leute da anzusprechen drauf
und hier auch wichtig zu machen.
Dass er das fotografiert und anzeigt,
meinetwegen.
Aber dann auch irgendwie den Leuten auf den Sack gehen,
ich weiß nicht.
Da hätte man aber auch auf dem Kirchplatz parken können.
Ja.
Da hat ihm jetzt schon ein Knöllchen gegeben.
Wie finden Sie das?
Da hat ihm überhaupt kein Knöllchen gegeben.
Gehe ich dann Post?
Ich denke mal vom Ordnungsamt.
Das Ordnungsamt muss dann gucken,
was es daraus macht.
Also da sind der Ordnungsamt der Unterschied.
Der Typ denkt sich gerade,
Alter, was willst du von mir?
Manche versenden Knöllchen, manche nicht.
Ihr habt recht, ein bisschen cringe ist es.
Das ist sehr unterschiedlich, je nachdem,
wie viel die zu tun haben.
Dieser Herr ist übrigens sein Nachbar.
Doch Niklas kennt keine Gnade.
Schließlich hat er ein ambitioniertes Projekt vor sich.
Also mein Ziel ist es,
in jeder Stadt und in jeder Gemeinde,
in ganz Deutschland,
mindestens einen Falschparker angezeigt zu haben.
Und dann kommen Sie ins Guinness-Buch der Rekorde.
Kann sein, zumindest ein Deutscher.
Jeder hat seine eigenen Ziele.
Das ist sicherlich eine Leistung,
die ich als Erster verbracht habe.
Ganz ehrlich,
ich muss jetzt auch mal,
wie soll ich sagen,
auch in so einem vielleicht etwas unangenehmen Fall,
sagen wir mal,
etwas vertreten,
was ich schon an anderer Stelle gesagt habe.
Man kann durchaus
auf seine Leistung stolz sein.
Ob das was ist,
wo ich mich ja dünnst mit identifizieren kann,
sei mal dahingestellt.
Aber es ist eine Leistung.
Das musst du erst mal schaffen.
Es wirkt schon ein bisschen super pingelig.
Es gab ja auch früher die Leute,
die gesagt haben,
Platz 1 in irgendeinem Competitive-Spiel
online zu erreichen,
ist keine Leistung,
weil es ist ja nur ein Game.
Man muss es erst mal schaffen.
Auch wenn das vielleicht was ist,
was ich jetzt nicht so geil finde.
Zunächst.
Ich kann,
sonntags da rumfahren,
aber gut,
jeder hat so seine eigenen Dinger.
In seiner Heimatstadt für Ordnung.
Im letzten Jahr hat er insgesamt
4000 Anzeigen geschrieben.
Bei so viel Engagement drücken wir
diesen Verstoß gegen die Vorfahrtsregel
mal beide Augen zu.
Der nächste Fall.
In der Gartenstraße steht ein Auto
rechtswidrig vor einer Dönerbude.
Ist das Ihr Auto?
Der parkt auf dem Gehweg.
Das, ganz ehrlich,
das Fotografieren und Anzeigen,
ja, aber dieses
die Leute darauf ansprechen,
das finde ich schon zu vieles Guten.
Ich habe gerade ihm Ware gebracht.
Ich mache gleich weg.
Ein- und ausladen, halten dürfen Sie auch hier.
Bitte?
Hier geht nicht?
Das ist ein Gehweg, darf er nicht.
Hier dürfen Sie halten.
So lange, wie es beim Halten bleibt,
wären das 55 Euro.
Am Hauptbahnhof hätten Sie ihn wahrscheinlich
schon abgestochen, ey.
Jetzt drücken Sie aber ein Auge zu, oder?
Nee. Grundsätzlich nicht.
Also muss er das ordnen und gucken,
was er daraus macht.
Wie finden Sie das?
Zehn Minuten, noch nicht mal zehn Minuten.
Ich kann auch meine Ware zeigen.
Hier ist mein Laden, ich bringe meine Ware.
Warum sollte das verboten sein?
Nö.
Warum sollte, seriously,
warum sollte das verboten sein?
Der Typ macht ein Foto, legt das hoch,
der ist ja nicht selbst die Polizei,
in dem Sinne, der legt das hoch,
das Ordnungsamt guckt sich das an,
verfolgt das weiter, ist doch vollkommen okay,
Hinweise zu geben.
Da sehe ich jetzt
kein Problem drinne.
Das muss man bei anderen Sachen doch auch haben.
Ja.
Was ich eher blöd finde, ist,
dass er den Leuten noch zusätzlich auf den Sack geht
mit, wissen Sie denn, dass Sie da auch woanders
parken können und so.
Das würde mich nerven.
Dieses Fotografieren und Hochladen ans Ordnungsamt,
okay, ey,
wenn er Bock drauf hat, soll er machen.
Die müssen ja auch nicht falsch parken, ja.
Aber die Leute nerven, das ist halt...
Oder außerdem,
Rico, ich wollte gerade was ähnliches sagen.
Außerdem gehen mir auch Autofahrer
genug auf den Sack, ja.
Ich lade auf und dann mache ich zu
und dann bringe ich zu meinem Parkplatz mein Auto.
Dann wird die Lage dynamisch.
Oh, oh, oh, oh!
Jetzt geht's los!
Was geht jetzt?
Weiß ich nicht.
Wenn Sie die Polizei haben wollen,
kommen und die holen.
Ich nicht, nee.
Ich bin Privatperson.
Wie geht das jetzt weiter?
Genau.
Boah, da hätte ich ja
so keinen Bock drauf.
Alter!
Ja, aber weswegen wollen die die Polizei rufen?
Ich meine, das sollte ihnen klar sein,
dass es im Zweifelsfall für die
negativ endet, wenn sie jetzt die Polizei rufen.
Dann hat die Polizei schwarz auf weiß,
das Ding steht falsch.
Routine. Denn allein in der
11.000 Einwohner Stadt hat er rechnerisch
schon rund 8% der Bevölkerung
angeschwärzt.
Ja, das ist ja vielleicht nicht ganz normal.
Es mag sein, aber was ist schon normal?
Ja, 32.875.
Wir sind auch nicht normal, Chat.
Und mit 902 Falschparkern.
Oder 903, so ja.
Ja.
Und jetzt haben wir übrigens ein Parken.
Aber sag mal so,
dass Leute darauf ansprechen,
finde ich schon etwas cringe.
Das Melden?
Warum nicht?
Wenn es einem Spaß macht,
zwingt dir ja auch keiner,
falsch zu parken.
Da musst du mit rechnen,
gemeldet zu werden.
Es ist nichts, was ich jetzt
selbst praktizieren würde.
Es wäre mir die Zeit zu schade.
Aber dass die Leute darauf ansprechen,
ich weiß nicht.
Ganz offensichtlich keiner.
Aber wie gesagt, Frankfurt Hauptbahnhof
würde ich das nicht machen.
Ausladevorgang, ja.
Dann kommt die Verstärkung.
Die kennen den Typ schon, oder?
Ja.
Ich weiß nicht,
ob die Leute da vorne stehen können.
Niklas Matthei macht Meldung.
Hallo, Anzeigenhauptmeister und Matthei.
Oh, Anzeigenhauptmeister.
Das ist schon ein bisschen cringe jetzt.
Es geht um den Falschparker da drüben.
Ich habe ihn halt erfasst.
Und wollte letztendlich,
dass die Polizei dazukommt,
habe ich den Wunsch erfüllt.
Unter dem wachsamen Blick
des Anzeigenhauptmeisters
findet der Parkverstoß...
Der hat ja auch so ein bisschen salutiert,
bei Anzeigenhauptmeister.
...ein jähes Ende.
Niklas hat aber noch ein weiteres Anliegen.
Kann ich hier so lange
so ein Symbolfoto vom Streifen machen?
Rico sagt,
ich finde das nicht mehr oder weniger cringe
als GTA-Roleplay.
Es hat ein bisschen was von GTA-Roleplay.
Ohne Scheiß.
Es hat echt was
von GTA-Roleplay gerade.
So was?
Kann ich hier so ein Symbolfoto
seitlich so auf dem Streifen machen?
Sie selber oder mit der Kamera?
Solange ich jetzt auf dem Foto drauf bin?
Ja.
Ein kurzer Schnappschuss
für die private Einsatzdokumentation.
Wäre der Knöllchen fetischist,
ist vielleicht selbst gerne Polizist?
Bei Ihnen steht ja auch Polizei vorne dran.
Nee, nicht ganz.
Da steht Polizphie.
Das, was eigentlich im E normalerweise ist,
das ist hier bei mir ein F.
Aber wer hat nicht einen Dachschaden?
Ich habe quasi ein eigenes Wort kreiert,
was halt somit nicht mal verboten ist.
Also verboten sind halt nur Hoheitszeichen.
Also ich dürfte jetzt mal keinen Bundeswappen,
also so ein Bundesator oder sowas.
Naja, das ist die Polizei.
An den Staat gekommen ist, lag an denen.
Die wollten die Polizei haben.
Sterne, solche Hoheitszeichen
durfte ich halt nicht verwenden.
Aber der Schriftzug an sich ist nicht verboten.
Und schon gar nicht, wenn er halt abgeändert ist.
Der Anzeigenhauptmeister ist unterwegs
Eine Anwohnerin hat offenbar
alle Fünfe gerade sein lassen.
Der parkt auf dem Gehweg und behindert
dadurch andere Verkehrsteilnehmer.
Was bedeutet das?
Okay Leute, kontroverse Frage
an euch.
Was findet ihr nerviger?
Sowas, was der macht?
Oder wenn sich Leute festkleben
auf der Straße?
Jetzt mal ganz wertungsfrei, würde mich einfach interessieren.
Was findet ihr nerviger?
Beides? Ja, okay.
Chat, chat, ich mag...
Ihr seid pfeifert.
Ich hab drauf spekuliert.
Ich hab gehofft.
Ich hab gehofft, dass ihr schreibt beides.
Und glücklicherweise schreibt ihr auch
zum größten Teil beides.
Ich find auch beides nervig.
Es ist unterschiedlicher Art
nervig.
Ich werde dadurch behindert.
Kann ich da mal demonstrieren?
Dass die Behinderung
verwirklicht ist.
Ja wirklich, da hat schon ein Beamten-Deutsch drauf.
Das ist nämlich immer mal ganz gerne so,
stelle ich mein Fahrrad einfach ab,
laufe ich jetzt als Fußgänger hier,
muss jetzt einmal drum rum ums Fahrzeug
und schon haben wir die Behinderung verwirklicht.
Es ist halt schon eine Kack-Position da zu stehen.
So ist es nicht.
Da ist die Behinderung dabei.
Also ich würde mich da auch aufregen,
wenn ich da vorbeilaufen müsste,
wenn ich irgendwas schieben müsste.
Die Oma mit Rollator, den Einkaufstrolli
oder was auch immer.
Oder vielleicht ist das auch ein Fahrradweg.
Das ist kein Fahrradweg.
Das würde mich auch schon abfangen.
Ich würde den Typen nicht fotografieren und hochladen,
aber ärgern würde es mich auch, wenn ich da langlaufen muss.
Kostet 70 Euro.
Außerdem haben sie jetzt die Behinderung verwirklicht.
Klingt sich,
wie das klingt, Alter.
Ist bei euch auch die Behinderung verwirklicht?
Punkt.
Willst du nicht mal
Arbeit suchen oder so?
Echt? Ja.
Wahrscheinlich hat die das gesagt,
was sich so 90 Prozent der Leute denken.
Na ja, wo wäre denn das Problem,
das Fahrzeug auf der Straße zu parken?
Wie der da hinten, der kann es doch auch.
Hat der mal Arbeit und dann ist es gut.
Hab ich.
Hallo.
Apropos Arbeit.
Niklas macht gerade eine Ausbildung
im medizinischen Bereich.
Trotzdem treibt er mit seinem Wochenend-Hobby
den Blutdruck von so manchem gewaltig nach oben.
Warte, ich hab die Fuhre.
Das gibt eine Anzeige wegen Beleidigung.
Jetzt geht's ab.
Direkt die Polizei rufen wieder.
Du Vogel.
Ist das schon, ist das schon,
ist das überhaupt schon
Beleidigung, Mann?
Nach oben.
Mache dich ab, du Vogel.
Das gibt eine Anzeige wegen Beleidigung.
Mache.
Ab.
Du stehst hier auch auf dem Grundstück.
Ja, du hast nicht eingezählt, darf man ja auch.
Der ist aber, eins muss man
ihm lassen, eins muss man ihm lassen.
Der ist eiskalt bei
bei der Sache, ja.
Den, den,
also weiß ich, den schockt's
überhaupt nicht. Der ist da, der ist da,
der ist abgebrüht, ja, was das angeht.
Wie gesagt,
Frankfurt Hauptbahnhof würde ich mir
Gedanken um seine Gesundheit machen.
An den Knöllchen
verdient er nichts.
Eine Beleidigung ist da schon lukrativer.
Manchmal sagt er, beschuldigt er sich auch bei der
Polizei aus. Ja, ich hab's nicht so gemeint.
Das ist ein eindeutiger Beweis.
Erhebe ich dann privatklare,
also zivilrechtlich auf
Schadensersatz beim zuständigen Amtsgericht
und
dann kann ich damit abkassieren.
Warum er sich nicht beim Ordnungsamt bewirbt,
ich glaube, keine Ahnung,
der will das nicht
hauptberuflich oder irgendwie,
der will das einfach nur so als Hobby
nebenbei machen,
um sich,
ich weiß, keine Ahnung, schwer zu sagen,
ich glaube nicht, dass er da irgendwie hauptberuflich
das auch verantwortungsmäßig machen will.
Er will einfach nur ein bisschen,
wenn's ihm danach ist,
seinen Rekord da.
Außerdem arbeitet
er am Sonntag nachher.
Das heißt?
Naja, da gibt's vielleicht mal 50 Euro,
mal 100 Euro, also so eine kleinen
unteren dreistelligen Beträge.
Weiter geht's. Die Nervensäge im Namen
von Recht und Ordnung hat einen
Volkswagen im Visier.
Oh, er steht falsch rum.
Er steht falsch rum. Und ein bisschen zu dicht
alles, ne?
Der parkt auf der linken Fahrbahnseite.
Aber die anderen ja auch.
Nee, die parken rechts.
Und der parkt links.
Ja, das war ja offensichtlich, das habe sogar ich erkannt.
Also Fahrtrichtung links. Die parken in Fahrtrichtung rechts,
der in Fahrtrichtung links.
Er gibt sich aber nicht illegal als Polizist aus.
Nummer 112
Auf die Frage hin,
gehören Sie zur Polizei, sagt er immer
nein.
Warum machen Sie das? Stört doch eigentlich niemanden.
Bei Ihnen stört das.
Mit den 15 Euro können Sie vielleicht im Rathaus...
Ja, Bugelkuch, das finde ich auch.
Der Reporter hört sich nicht sonderlich neutral an.
Es ist auch schwer,
neutral zu sein bei dem Thema, aber
zumindest als Kamerateam und da
sollte man vielleicht ein bisschen
nicht so
vorwurfsvoll klingen.
Sascha Silber, danke für den Sub.
Zwei neue
Glühbirnen kaufen.
Kommt das auch der Stadtkasse zugute?
Dann, kurz vor Feierabend, gibt es für
Mattei noch einen...
Lässiger Lord Nedo, danke für den Sub, ich habe ihn übersehen.
... im Lotto.
Sieben Falschparker auf
Sieben Stück, jetzt
ist er in seinem Element.
Bei dem kommt noch dazu,
parken vor einer Burschenabsenkung, das darf man auch nicht.
Auch nicht, wenn es die eigene ist?
Richtig, nach SDVO
nein.
Die ganze Straße in Sippenhaft nimmt
es einfach, mehr oder weniger.
Hier steht Verkehrszeichen 250,
Verbot der Durchfahrt für alle
Fahrzeuge.
Heißt, die dürfen hier nicht reinfahren,
demzufolge auch nicht parken.
Das ist in dem Fall Parken in einem Verkehrsbereich,
der durch Zeichen 250 gesperrt war.
Ey, ey, du musst sie belasten. Ahnung hat er.
Zumindest klingt das so.
Bilanz der dreistündigen Streife,
12 Anzeigen wegen Falschparkens.
Davon kann die Gemeinde jetzt eine Menge...
Darf man sein Rad auf der Fahrbahn schieben?
Wahrscheinlich schon, ja.
... Glühbirnen kaufen.
Ein neuer Tag im Kampf
um die Straßenverkehrsordnung.
Du darfst ja auch auf der Straße laufen.
Würde man nicht unbedingt empfehlen, aber...
Für den Knöllchenjäger geht es heute
von Sachsen-Anhalt nach Niedersachsen.
Das Deutschlandticket macht es möglich.
Er hat coole Outfits.
Er hat ein gelbes Outfit, ein orangenes Outfit.
Hat er auch ein grünes?
Sie sind ein Denunziant.
Naja, gewissermaßen
kann man das so sagen.
Man hört ja alle an, Scheiß.
Wenn man das so aus der Perspektive betrachtet,
kann man das schon so sehen.
Wäre jetzt jedenfalls nicht verkehrt.
Finden Sie das aber nicht schlimm?
Nein.
Warum nicht?
Naja, weil das letztendlich,
was ich tue,
kommt der Allgemeinheit zugute.
Das schadet zwar dem Einzelnen,
der Falschparker...
Neues Questgebiet freigeschaltet.
Auf nach Niedersachsen.
Die hatten Nützen darin.
Buxtehude, 11.30 Uhr.
Der Helm sitzt.
Schon auf dem Bahnhofsvorplatz fallen dem Anschwärzer
vom Dienst abgelaufene TÜV-Plaketten auf.
Oh, oh, oh.
Das bleibt nicht ungeahndet.
Das haben Sie so schnell gesehen?
Ja.
Kennt man doch schon an der Farbe.
Hier haben wir gleich den nächsten.
Die ist seit November.
Die ist schon im Bußgeldbereich.
Was mich interessieren würde,
was der ans Ordnungsamt schickt,
wird dann letztendlich auch bearbeitet
und...
folgt dann irgendein Bescheid raus.
Buxtehude scheint
ein heißes Pflaster zu sein.
Ich war auch schon in Gemeinden.
Da habe ich eine Stunde gebraucht,
bis ich einen ersten gefunden habe.
Und hier habe ich jetzt drei
in den ersten zehn Minuten.
Die Stadt, ein einziger Park-Sündenpfuhl.
Genug zu tun für den informellen Mitarbeiter
der Ordnungsmacht.
Nach nur wenigen Metern
fällt ihm ein Verstoß
nach § 12 Absatz 4 StVO auf.
Macht 55 Euro.
Das steht auf dem Gehweg.
Auf dem Gehweg darf man mit dem Kraftfahrzeug nicht fahren.
Nicht halten, nicht parken, nicht drauf fahren.
Und wer sind Sie?
Ich bin Privatperson.
Der deutsche Anzeigenhauptmeister.
Das klingt so schräg, Alter.
Ja, super.
Und wir sind die großen Denunzianten, oder wie?
Ne, den Verein kenne ich auch nicht.
Ja, da sind Sie aber offensichtlich drin involviert.
Er ist ein Denunziant. Fertig.
Wir haben da unser Büro.
Wir haben unser Büro da.
Wir dürfen selbstverständlich hier kurz anhalten
und Sachen da reinbringen.
Das machen wir gerade in den Tisch.
Und er hat nichts besseres vor, als uns zu fotografieren.
Mein Recht auf Privatsphäre
einzuschränken.
Dann rufen Sie jetzt die Polizei. Dann klären wir das.
Gut, dann machen wir das natürlich.
Die Leute sind auch schon doof, oder?
Warum wollen die jetzt die Polizei rufen?
Das geht nur negativ für die aus.
Dann sieht's die Polizei
live vor Ort, dass der falsch steht.
Hallo? Ähm, können Sie bitte...
Hallo? Hallo?
Hören Sie mich? Ja.
Der ist Rechtsanwalt. Okay, jetzt geht's ab.
Dann ist er doch nicht blöd. Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt.
Können Sie bitte einen Streifenwagen schicken?
Ähm, hier gibt's Streitigkeiten mit einem
Falschbroker, den ich halt als Privatperson
erfasst habe. Und der ist nicht damit einverstanden,
dass ich ihn erfasst habe.
Und, ähm, da hätte gerne die Polizei dazu.
Es ist folgendes Problem...
Ja, die haben auch Besseres zu tun, oder?
Wir räumen gerade
in unserem Büro ein paar Tische
aus und ein. Und jetzt kommt dieser Vogel hier an
und... Oh! Oh! Vogel!
Direkt am Handy! Bam! Anzeige!
...
Da müssen wir uns jetzt aussuchen, was sie scherzhaft meinen und was nicht.
Das schüttert ja damit nicht.
Nein, ich glaube, dass sie sich hier ein Amt anmaßen, was sie nicht haben.
Aber das kann ja gleich die Polizei klären.
Da kommt sie schon.
Doch auch die echten Beamten sind offenbar nicht richtig zu erkennen,
meint zumindest der Polizfist.
Uh, das Kennzeichen ist aber dreckig.
Keine Gnade, Leute! Keine Gnade!
Alle! Der gibt gleich Anzeige bei der Polizei auf.
Der ist eiskalt, das ist ein Gedächtnis.
Next Level.
Das Kennzeichen müssen die auch mal sauber machen.
Das Kennzeichen wäre schön, wenn sie das auch mal sauber machen würden.
Wenn das auch nicht mehr lesbar ist.
Der pisst sich innerlich auch weg, ey, der Typ.
Jetzt soll ich die Kennzeichen sauber machen.
Ja, müssen sie jetzt noch nicht.
Jetzt geht das noch, aber wenn es noch dreckiger wird, dann kostet das auch mal 5 Euro.
Das ist ein Selbstkrieger.
Das wird das Wort.
Also wer da meint, dass das tatsächlich echt ist, äh...
Das steht auch nicht für die Polizei.
Nee.
Ist das keine Amtsanmaßung?
Überhaupt nicht.
Ach ja, und falls sie mal auf der Ware Zeit haben...
Oh nein, ist das cringe!
Er erzählt ihnen jetzt doch bitte nicht, dass sie das noch mal schön sauber machen sollen, oder?
Oh nee.
Das Kennzeichen wäre vielleicht gut, wenn sie das auch mal sauber machen.
Also muss jetzt noch nicht, aber wenn es dann immer weiter dreckig wird, sieht das doch nicht so schön aus.
Wenn sie mal Zeit haben.
Der ist ja wirklich gnadenlos, muss man ja sagen.
Zeit zum Putzen haben die Beamten ja, jetzt wo Matthei ihre Arbeit macht.
Weiter jetzt.
Hase und Igel, die muckste Hude, und auch Meister Petzl ist immer schon da.
Also die dürfen ja nicht stehen.
Und der noch dazu auf dem Gehweg.
Macht wie viel?
Mit Behinderung 70 Euro und einen Punkt.
Und der hat...
Der hat eine 8-Milo-Fritz-Tüftelkette.
Ich glaube, der ist so konsequent, dass er sogar sich selbst reporten würde, wenn er falsch steht.
Seiner Passion geht es schon seit drei Jahren nach.
Da kommt das zusammen.
Ich war letztes Jahr in 84 Städten und Gemeinden in Deutschland.
Und ich habe insgesamt für alle Städte und Gemeinden, wo ich war, 140.975 Euro erwirtschaftet.
Wie viel?
Für alle Städte und Gemeinden, wo ich war, 140.975 Euro erwirtschaftet.
140.975 Euro erwirtschaftet.
Ja, und das hat eine Menge Geld.
Mit vier...
Jeder, was er will.
Mit 4.247.
Das ist nicht verboten.
Nur mit 4.
Ich finde es auch ein bisschen cringe.
Das ist nicht verboten.
Außerdem zwingt die Leute, keiner falsch zu stehen.
Ich finde es auch, letztendlich total übertrieben, jemand, der sich kurz dahinstellt, was auslädt.
Ob das Ganze dann wirklich weiter verfolgt wird, ob da was kommt, weiß man ja nicht.
Verboten ist das nicht.
Nur im letzten Jahr.
Davor, die Anzeigen kommen ja auch noch dazu.
Also, guck mal, das ist wie mit meinem Nachbar.
Die stehen ja auch teilweise oft halb vorm Tor.
Das geht mir auch auf den Sack.
Aber ich gehe denen damit nicht auf den Sack.
Und wenn ich mich mal irgendwo ein bisschen schepp hinstellen muss, oder irgendwie im Garten
irgendwas da über den Zaun hängt oder so, dann sagt er auch, okay, geht mir vielleicht
auf den Sack, aber ich sage auch nichts.
Auf der anderen Seite, ich bin ja nicht derjenige, der sagt, ich bin nicht derjenige, der nicht
auf den Sack geht.
Ich bin derjenige, der nicht auf den Sack geht.
Auf der anderen Seite gibt es Leute, so ein bisschen wahrscheinlich wie er hier, kleine,
kleine Story am Rande.
Bei uns im Garten wurde ein Baum gefällt nach Anmeldung beim Forstamt, nee, keine Ahnung,
Ordnungsamt, Ordnungsamt, Ordnungsamt.
Also wann auch immer man das anmelden muss.
Wir haben einen Baum gefällt, also nicht wir, sondern eine Firma war da, hat einen Baum
gefällt.
Und der Baum lag dann da einen Monat rum und dann kam eine andere Firma, hat den Baum klein gemacht und hat den Baum abtransportiert.
Und auf einmal steht das Ordnungsamt bei uns vor der Tür und sagt, anonymer Anruf, wir würden hier zu Zeiten, wo es nicht erlaubt wäre, quasi unerlaubt einen Baum fällen.
Und dann haben wir den in den Garten geführt, haben ihm das gezeigt, haben gesagt, guck mal hier, wir fällen den Baum nicht, der Baum liegt da schon eine Weile.
Außerdem haben wir die Genehmigung dafür gehabt und dann ist er wieder abgedüst.
Also sprich, einer von unseren Nachbarn war ein bisschen drauf, wie der Anzeigenhauptmeister, hat bei sich aus dem Fenster geguckt, hat gesehen, oh, oh, bei Max im Garten, da wird an einem Baum rumgeschnippelt.
Zu dieser Jahreszeit darf man das eigentlich nicht und hat dann beim Ordnungsamt angerufen.
Also Leute gibt es überall.
Für letztes Jahr, also für 2022 haben wir noch keine Statistik erstellt. Mit der Statistik, das mache ich erst seit 2023.
Die jahrelange Erfahrung schärft den Blick fürs Detail. Eine mit sieben Metern ausgewiesene Ladezone kommt dem Kundschaft der Verderbten.
Ich fasse es nicht, Alter. Der hat einen Zollstock dabei.
Der hat einen Zollstock dabei, um sowas auszumessen.
Oh Mann, Alter.
Also der ist wirklich gnadenlos, der Typ.
Richtig zugepackt vor. Wer nimmt lieber noch einmal Maß?
Das sind sechs.
Ja, also die sieben Meter gehen in dem Fall bis in etwa hierher.
Man darf garantiert Kreide malen, das ist erlaubt.
Ja, und die sieben Meter beginnen halt, wo das Holz steht. Das habe ich jetzt vermessen.
Und das steht halt drinnen.
Genau.
Aber muss der Autofahrer dann den Zollstock dabei haben?
Muss er nicht, der muss halt nur gut schätzen können. Hier in dem Fall hat er sich verschätzt.
Ja, genau.
Sieben Meter sind sieben Meter.
Und was soll man das verschätzen?
Das kostet dem jetzt 25 Euro.
Also da steht circa einen Meter im absoluten Haltverbot.
Genau.
Anzeige direkt raus.
Circa einen Meter.
Ist das nicht ein bisschen kleinlich jetzt?
Ja, aber Gesetz ist halt Gesetz.
Ich wusste, dass die Antwort kommt.
Dann steht da sieben Meter und nicht sechs Meter.
Ist auch egal, ob da jetzt hier so eine Pflastersteine sind, das spielt keine Rolle.
Das Schild geht.
Und das Schild sagt, das absolute Haltverbot geht nicht bis dahin, sondern bis dahin.
Der würde den auch bei zwei Zentimetern drüber fotografieren.
Dann steht da einen Meter im absoluten Haltverbot.
Jetzt noch schnell eine abgelaufene Parkscheibe aufschreiben.
Ja, da ist zwölf Uhr ange...
Dann ein Unfall.
Das Dienstfahrrad ist umgefallen.
Das war nicht weiter passiert.
Doch, ein Kratzer.
Oh nein.
Den Unfallort darf man nicht verlassen.
Das wäre Fahrerflucht.
Also ruft er die Polizei.
Okay, der ist wirklich...
Er ist hart drauf.
Dieses Mal in eigener Sache.
Hallo.
Ich hatte angerufen.
Verrückte Welt in Buxtehude.
Matthai wird wegen einer Ordnungswidrigkeit belehrt.
Und zwar von einer echten Polizistin.
Weil Sie den Fehler gemacht haben, haben Sie die Ordnungswidrigkeit begangen.
Das, was ich Ihnen vorhin erklärt habe, die Belehrung.
Das ist ja umgefallen.
Genau, weil Sie müssen dafür sorgen, dass das Fahrrad nicht umfallen kann, wenn Sie es abstellen.
Weil Sie sind verantwortlich dafür.
Der Verstoß, der kostet 35 Euro.
Sie können das hier vor Ort zugreifen.
Ich könnte Sie, wenn Sie eine EC-Karte dabei haben, hier vor Ort bezahlen.
Man kann direkt live bezahlen mittlerweile.
Ansonsten würde ich das an den Landkreis schicken und Sie bekommen Post.
Machen Sie das an den Landkreis.
Weil der Landkreis die zuständige Verfolgungsbehörde ist.
Ja, dann machen Sie das an den Landkreis.
An den Landkreis.
Sicherheitshalber nochmal die Parkzeit beim Unfallopfer überprüfen.
Vielleicht hätte der ja gar nicht...
Vielleicht holt er die 35 Euro wieder raus.
Es müssen sich jetzt nur noch ein paar Leute als Vogel beleidigen.
Dann sind die 35 Euro easy wieder drin.
Ja.
Das war ja...
Bilanz des Tages.
27 angezeigte Ordnungswidrigkeiten.
Kleiner Service-Tipp zum Ende.
Niklas Matthais nächstes Ziel ist Passau.
Das muss man ihm echt lassen.
Der ruft da auch selbst an.
Gut, man weiß jetzt nicht, was gewesen wäre, wenn die Polizei...
Nicht die Polizei, wenn das Kamerateam nicht dabei gewesen wäre.
Darfst du der Reporter...
Der Reporter.
Nee, das glaube ich nicht.
Die waren zwar ein bisschen voreingenommen,
aber das glaube ich, what the fuck, das glaube ich nicht.
Ist halt die Frage, ob es da überhaupt
einen Schaden gegeben hat.
Oh man, der Anzeigenhauptmeister.
Was nicht alles gibt, ey.
Also ich muss sagen, am besten war,
wenn man der Polizei erzählt hat,
ihr Nummernschild ist dreckig.
Ja.
Und ihm geht es ja offensichtlich auch nicht darum,
dass er irgendwie damit fette Kohle machen würde oder so.
Ja.
Es zwingt die Leute auch, keiner falsch zu parken.
Aber klar, es ist schon sehr kleinlich.
Und eigentlich würde ich sagen,
ey,
lass es halt gut sein.
Ja gut.
Anzeigenhauptmeister.
Die kennen den doch garantiert alle schon beim Anrufen.
Mein Opa,
weil wir es am Anfang von meinem Opa hatten,
mein Opa hatte auch so ein bisschen,
ein bisschen was davon.
Und zwar, immer wenn irgendjemand
vom Haus geparkt hat, wohlgemerkt vom Haus darf man parken,
hat er quasi buchgeführt,
wie lang der da steht.
Also buchgeistig buchgeführt.
Wobei, weiß ich nicht,
ob der nicht wirklich einen Zettel vielleicht sogar hatte.
Aber ich glaube, der hatte keinen Zettel.
Mein Opa hat immer getrackt,
wie lang stehen Autos
oder LKWs oder sonst was
vorm Haus.
Und er hat auch schon bei der Polizei angerufen,
wenn irgendwie mal einer drei, vier Tage am Stück da stand,
ohne sich bewegt zu haben.
So nach dem Motto, da steht einer vorm Haus
seit vier Tagen und was weiß ich,
was er denen erzählt hat.
Also da war er auch ein bisschen Anzeigenhauptmeister.
Aber nur, wenn es darum ging,
dass einer vorm eigenen Haus steht.
Ich gehe mal davon aus, das ist beides.
Der hat so einen sehr
ausgeprägten eigenen Ordnungssinn.
Und ich könnte mir durchaus
vorstellen, dass er schon ein paar Leute abfacken will.
Ja, was auch immer.
Verboten ist es auf jeden Fall nicht.
Und ganz ehrlich, es gibt auch
Schlimmeres. Das ist halt nervig, okay?
Aber es gibt deutlich Schlimmeres.
Gibt sowas in anderen Ländern auch,
ob es exakt sowas gibt,
aber es gibt überall überkorrekte Leute.
Die wirst du überall finden.
In irgendeiner Ausprägung.
Superkorrekte.
Überkorrekte.
Überall hast du die.
Okay.
So, was war das nächste jetzt?
Was hast du da?
Das da?
WiFi 7 wollte ich mir angucken.
WiFi 7 getestet.
Also ich bin aktuell noch
bei einem WiFi
5?
Access Point, glaube ich.
Moment.
WiFi, was
habt ihr hier?
802.11ac ist was?
WiFi 5, gell?
An die High IQ
Netzwerk
IEEE Standard Kenner.
Ist das WiFi 5?
Ja.
Das ist WiFi 5.
IEEE 802.11ac.
Da hänge ich noch
aktuell drauf. Und...
Und ich hab überhaupt keine Probleme
mit meinen Mobile-Geräten.
Und mit meinen Micro-Controller
und Raspberry Pi. Es funktioniert wirklich
erstklassig. Was aber auch daran
liegt, dass das ziemlich gute Access Points sind.
Sollen wir mal einen Wettbewerb machen?
Ach, ist das die Seite, wo man
reporten kann, wie die Leute falsch...
wo die Leute falsch parken?
Der Bongo-Car oder Anzeigen-Haupt...
Moment, der Anzeigen-Hauptmeister ist nur
auf Platz 2.
What's going on?
Let's go to the next one.
Okay, lass uns mal erklären,
ob WiFi 6 taugt.
Äh, WiFi 7.
Die meisten Leute haben nicht mal WiFi 6 Access Points.
Ist WiFi 6 überhaupt
schon offiziell gestandard...
standardized in allen Varianten
mittlerweile?
Weil WiFi 6 gab es schon, bevor
der Standard final war.
Also, da gab es schon erste
Geräte, bevor der Standard final war.
Ganz weird.
Also, 375 Megabyte
pro Sekunde.
Ja, unter optimalsten Bedingungen
zwei Meter vom Access Point weg.
Schaffen viele normale Festplatten nicht mal.
Und auch die meisten Kabel-LAN-Verbindungen
nicht. Die erreichen nämlich auch maximal
nur einen Gigabit.
Das Schöne ist, das Schöne an Kabel
ist, das Kabel ist immer
gleich schnell.
Ja, auch wenn mal
einer die Mikrowelle einschaltet daneben.
Und
auch wenn der Nachbar noch ein paar Access Points hat
und auch wenn ich mich mal ein bisschen...
Wobei, ha, das war jetzt ein blödes Beispiel, Max.
Ich wollte sagen, auch wenn ich mal ein bisschen woanders hingehe.
Ja, das Kabel ist gleich schnell, aber das Kabel kommt
nicht mit.
Ah, hier ist wieder
so ein, guck mal, so ein
Tarnbomber.
Die Dinger.
Die sehen echt aus wie irgendwelche
speziellen Tarnkappenbomber.
Wi-Fi 7, der neue, heiße
Standard. Wir haben sieben Geräte
getestet, die Wi-Fi 7 unterstützen.
Ja, und die Kleins müssen auch Wi-Fi 7 können.
Und dabei natürlich auch ein paar Haken gefunden. Außerdem
erklären wir in diesem Video verständlich, wie
genau Wi-Fi 7 besser
ist als Wi-Fi 6.
Liebe Internet-Surfer, herzlich
willkommen hier bei...
Dieses Video wird gesponsert von
Hostinger. Hostinger bietet euch
einen Website-Baukasten mit
KI-Unterstützung. Für alle, die schnell
und einfach eine professionelle
Website erstellen wollen.
Ob die Texte so professionell dann sind?
Ganz ohne Programmierkenntnisse.
In dem Paket ist alles dabei,
was ihr braucht. Domain, Hosting
mit unbegrenzter Bandbreite,
SSL-Verschlüsselung, E-Mails
und der K... Wetten, wenn da der falsche
kommt, ist die Bandbreite gar nicht mehr unbegrenzt?
KI-Baukasten. Da könnt ihr dann einfach
hier auswählen, für was eure... Wobei,
wobei, es ist ja nur, es ist ja nur eine Homepage,
es ist ja kein, äh, kein Linux-Server, wo
ich irgendwie was
hosten könnte, was mehr Traffic...
...und sie kurz beschreiben. Und schon
habt ihr einen Entwurf. Den könnt ihr dann
nach euren Vorstellungen antasten und... Okay, wir skippen das mal kurz.
...hier, das ist mein Handy, wie es
bei mir zu Hause den Google-Speedtest
durchballert. Bin ich ziemlich stolz
drauf, dass ich hier so schnell unterwegs bin... Okay, Moment.
Zack, Zack,
ich mach's nochmal kurz. Speed,
Speed, Speed...
Nee, oh fuck, hab ich gar nicht mehr installiert,
die App.
Hm, ich bin... Also, mein Internetzugang ist
gar nicht so schnell, also das, äh,
funzt gar nicht. Ähm,
Speed... Speedtest?
Was nimmt man da für
eine App? Nimmt man immer noch die, die
normale Speedtest-App oder gibt's da mittlerweile eine bessere
für? Ich mach das so selten
auf meinem... Also, ich mein, ich könnte
einfach auch iPerf
oder so benutzen, auf dem Handy.
Bräuchte ich aber irgendeine Gegenstelle
bei mir. Okay, next,
next, next, continue, continue, don't
allow location,
continue,
not tracking, okay.
Reject all cookies, go.
Also, mal gespannt.
Ich hab 16,
16 Millisekunden Ping
und nur, Leute,
ich habe nur
Mbit grade, obwohl der Accesspoint nicht
weit weg ist von mir. Die Frage
ist,
liegt es an mir,
an meinem WLAN, an Vodafone oder an dem
Testing, an dem Testservice?
Ich lass es
grad nochmal ausführen.
Naja, 85.
85 Mbit
hab ich grade nur. Na gut, ich hab auch noch
einen alten WiFi 5 Accesspoint.
Kann ja schon sein, ne?
Mit 2,4 GHz WLAN?
Okay, geht nicht schneller.
Das ist eine berechtigte
Frage, in welchem ich mich befinde, aber
das macht... Das sieht man ja bei
iOS nicht richtig.
Ist mir aber auch wurscht.
Ist Funst.
Weiß. Weiter.
800 Mbit in der Sekunde.
WiFi 6 represent.
Ja, okay, ist ne Wahrheit total.
2020, denn jetzt gibt's
halt WiFi 7 oder
wie wir... Es ist doof, dass ich das auf dem Endgerät
nicht sehe. Kann man auf dem iPhone
iPhone Z
check if
2,4 GHz
oder 5 GHz? Aha!
Open
your settings.
Navigate to WiFi
Das ist gelogen.
Das stimmt überhaupt nicht.
Das stimmt überhaupt nicht. Das steht da überhaupt nicht.
Ist das ne AI generierte Seite
oder was? Das stimmt nicht.
Das ist schlicht und ergreifend
gelogen. Das ist irgendein
AI generierter Shit.
Das steht da überhaupt nicht.
Geil.
Das ist irgendeine AI generierte...
Das ist kompletter Bullshit.
Ah, hier.
Ich bleib dabei. Es geht halt einfach nicht.
Super Fachleute sagen,
IEEE
802.11
BE. Diese Zungenbrechenden...
Warum ist es jetzt eigentlich BE
und nicht wieder A irgendwas?
IEEE-Codes sind übrigens eigentlich
die korrekten technischen Bezeichnungen,
aber die WiFi Alliance
hat sich als Marketingbegriffe diese...
Ja, das ist genau so wie...
Ich wusste mal aus dem Kopf, was
ähm...
äh... VLAN war.
Einfach nur
X oder so.
802.1X
oder was war VLAN?
Ah, Q. Q, nicht X. Q, genau.
802.1Q
Ja, okay, 802.1
war schon richtig, aber nicht X, sondern Q.
WiFi plus Nummer
ausgedacht. Also nach 6
kommt jetzt halt WiFi 7.
Kann man sich besser merken
und kann man viel besser aus...
Ja, da sieht man mal, die machen das richtig.
Was die USB-Leute nicht auf die Reihe bekommen.
Sinnvolle Namen.
Ja, und dieses WiFi 7
soll in der Theorie, also
auf dem Papier, unfassbare
23 Gigabit pro Sekunde
schaffen. Aber nur bei
Access Points mit 8 Antennen, das ist halt so
Profi-Hardware für Konzerthallen
und sowas. Für zu Hause
gibt's nur Geräte mit 4 Antennen.
Die schaffen dann theoretisch
11,5 Gigabit pro Sekunde.
Was ja immer noch extrem viel ist.
Aber Spoiler-Alarm,
in unseren Tests mit 4 WiFi
7 Basen und 3 Clients
haben wir maximal
3,9 Gigabit gemessen. Und das
auch nur bei besten Bedingungen
und kurzzeitig. Dazu gleich mehr.
Erstmal ganz wichtig, was macht
WiFi 7 denn nun genau anders als
die Vorgänger? Das aufregendste
Feature ist auf jeden Fall
Multi-Link Operation, kurz
MLO. Ihr kennt das ja vielleicht,
auch wenn euer Router sowohl im
2,4 als auch im 5 Gigahertz
Band funkt, klinken sich eure Clients
oft in genau das Band ein,
was gerade nicht am besten funktioniert
und gehen da dann auch ungern
automatisch wieder raus. Hier mal ganz
vereinfacht erklärt. Es gibt seit
WiFi 6e
3 Funkbänder. Die nennt man
umgangssprachlich 6 Gigahertz,
5 Gigahertz und 2,4 Gigahertz.
Und je höher die Frequenz,
desto schneller das WLAN. Aber
umso schlechter kommt es auch durch Wände
durch. Was leider auch gilt,
je höher die Frequenz, desto geringer die
Reichweite. Wenn ihr also dicht dran
am Router seid und keine oder wenig
Mauern dazwischen habt, dann solltet
ihr 5 oder 6 Gigahertz verwenden.
Seid ihr weiter weg, lieber 2,4
Gigahertz, wenn ihr keine
Verbindungsabbrüche riskieren wollt.
Bislang galt... Das ist ja auch eines der
Gründe, warum LoRa so weit geht auf
Megahertz
oder 822?
Ich weiß es aus dem Kopf gar nicht. 433
oder 868,
genau. 422 oder
868, genau.
Leider entweder oder. Euer mit
dem Router verbundenes Gerät
musste sich für ein Band entscheiden, auf dem
es funkt. Aber jetzt mit
Wifi 7 und diesem MLO
geht das erstmals, dass
zwei Bänder gleichzeitig genutzt
werden können. Und das ermöglicht nicht nur
höhere Geschwindigkeiten, sondern auch
eine bessere Zuverlässigkeit. Stabilere, ja.
Und eine geringere Latenz, also
weniger Verzögerung. Leuchtet ja auch ein.
Das Ding ist, bis ich meine Access Points
upgraden kann auf Wifi 7,
ähm,
da wir noch ein paar Jahre vergehen,
weil die Dinger sind jetzt
schon schweineteuer noch gewesen,
weil es ja nicht
irgendwelche 115 Kack-Noob
Endanwender-Access Points sind,
und ich hab keinen Bock
1.500 Euro pro Access Point zu
bezahlen, wenn die neu sind. Also muss
ich noch ein paar Jahre warten. Also wenn
mehr Funkkanäle zur Verfügung stehen,
dann ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit auch höher, dass
gerade ein Funkkanal frei ist,
wenn was gesendet werden soll.
In der Praxis ist MLO aber
ziemlich komplex. Das muss auch noch
ein bisschen reifen. Also mein
CT-Kollege Ernst Ahlers hat auch
schon ein Wifi 7 Gerät
getestet. 100 Euro für max
teuer? Nein, meine Access Points haben
gebraucht, bei Ebay sogar
um die 200, 250 Euro
gekostet. Die Dinger sind
verdammt teuer neu. Kein
aktives MLO messen konnte. Also
es ist halt wirklich noch früh, es
gibt wenig Hardware und häufige
Firmware-Updates. Wenn ihr übrigens
genau wissen wollt, wie MLO und
andere Wifi 7 Features
funktionieren, auf heise plus gibt es
mehrere wirklich interessante Artikel
dazu. Der Link ist in der Beschreibung.
Also ich habe die Access Points aktuell
ein hier
an der Decke gegenüber im Wohnzimmer
und ein unten
im Keller
an der Wand.
Da ist das komplette Haus inklusive Terrasse
und drum herum alles gut abgedeckt.
Davon habe ich zwei und um
euch mal zu chocken, was dieser Krempel neu
kostet.
Niemand, also
ich würde mir das nicht neu kaufen.
Deswegen sage ich ja, die neue
Generation wird dann das gleiche kosten.
Aber halt, was kostet
so ein R750 aktuell?
Falls die überhaupt einen
haben. Gibt es doch nicht mal hier.
Oh, guck mal.
Nur 640 Dollar.
Die US-Variante muss
man noch flashen, dass man sie in Europa verwenden kann.
Ja, und hier kostet es
solche Schweine teuer.
Aber die haben halt sehr nice Features.
Warum sind die Dinger so teuer?
Weil das Enterprise
Geräte sind. Die sind allein schon, weil es
Enterprise Geräte sind, teuer.
Weil das teuer sein muss.
Ich glaube, es gibt keine wirkliche
so komplette Rechtfertigung,
warum die so viel teurer sein
müssen. Einfach, weil Enterprise
Geräte immer teurer sind. Aber die haben
ein paar ganz coole Features. Für mich
war wirklich das Killer-Feature damals,
warum ich mir die gekauft habe, ist,
dass du unterschiedliche Passwörter
vergeben kannst
für unterschiedliche Geräte.
Für das gleiche WLAN, wohlgemerkt.
Also du hast ein WLAN,
mein tolles WLAN,
und du kannst dort für unterschiedliche
Geräte unterschiedliche Passwörter vergeben.
Für das gleiche WLAN.
Das können mittlerweile
die meisten Hersteller
mehr oder weniger gut,
zumindest die bisschen teureren Hersteller.
Ich glaube, die Fritzbox wird das wahrscheinlich nie können.
OpenWrt kann das
auch nur mit ein bisschen gefuddel.
Unify kann es mittlerweile
auch. Da weiß ich nicht, wie gut.
Ich habe mein Unify schon eine Weile rausgeschmissen.
Aber das war damals der Grund,
warum ich umgestellt habe. Weil das einfach
sehr, sehr nice Feature ist,
wenn man IoT-Geräte benutzt,
die man auch mal ab und zu wegschmeißt.
Für IoT-Geräte zum Beispiel.
Stell dir vor, du hast
eine China-Chinesen-Smart-
Steckdosenleiste.
Die packst du in dein WLAN
und die geht kaputt und du schmeißt sie weg.
Dann ist ja immer noch dein
WLAN-Passwort da drauf.
Was ist die Alternative? Dein WLAN-Passwort ändern
und dann auf allen 60 Geräten, die es gerade verwenden?
Einmal durchbohren und fertig.
Weißt du, wo der Chip sitzt,
mit dem Speicher, wo du durchbohren musst?
Ja, ja, ja, wir haben
kein Browser-Add-on,
sondern
ein Tempermonkey-Script gebaut,
dafür, dass man noch ein bisschen
besser Passwörter generieren kann.
Das ist halt
wirklich nice. Stellt euch vor,
ihr habt ein Handy und
das ist kaputt,
ihr schmeißt es weg und
da drin ist ja immer noch
oder eine IoT-Klühbirne,
eine smarte Klühbirne,
da drin ist ja immer euer WLAN-Passwort.
Genau.
Und wenn du jedes Gerät hast,
wenn jedes Gerät ein eigenes Passwort hat,
gehst du in das Webinterface,
schmeißt das Gerät raus und es hat keinen WLAN-Zugang mehr
und niemand kann damit was anfangen.
Das ist schon nice, wenn man viele Geräte hat
im WLAN,
die potenziell auch mal weggeschmissen werden,
kaputtgehen und so.
Das löst halt das grundsätzliche Problem,
dass alle Geräte sich das gleiche
Passwort sharen.
Das ist ein sehr nice Feature.
Es kann nicht die Antwort
sein, einfach was anderes
zu verwenden immer.
Also nach dem Motto, ey,
ich hab keinen Bock auf Paint
und die Antwort wäre,
warum nicht einfach einen Mac verwenden?
Der Angriffsvektor
ist doch ganz offensichtlich.
Nehmen wir mal
eine Klühbirne.
Die Klühbirne braucht ein WLAN-Passwort.
Also eine smarte Klühbirne.
Leuchtmittel, muss man da korrekt
dabei sagen.
Die muss in dein WLAN rein.
Also hat die
auf ihrem Speicher
in der Klühbirne
dein WLAN-Passwort.
Die Klühbirne geht kaputt.
Du schmeißt die Klühbirne in Müll
und damit liegt potenziell
dein WLAN-Passwort
im Müll.
Für jeden, den es interessiert, auslesbar.
Den Angriffsvektor
habe ich ja gerade beschrieben, der ist ziemlich offensichtlich, oder?
Alles, jedes Gerät,
was im WLAN war, was du nicht mehr löschen
kannst, was du wegschmeißt,
hat potenziell dein WLAN-Passwort drinne.
Wie wahrscheinlich das jetzt
ist, dass das jemand macht.
Ja, da kann man sich jetzt überlegen,
wie hoch der Keck-Alu-Faktor ist.
Aber das ist ein bisschen wie
private Daten im Internet verteilen.
Oder Sachen verschlüsseln im Internet
verteilen. Alles, was nicht verteilt
wurde, kann keine Probleme machen.
Das ist da genau das Gleiche.
Der gleiche Grund, warum man seine Festplatten
verschlüsseln sollte. Nicht, weil man
Angst vor den bösen FBI-Hackermans hat,
sondern unter anderem, weil man seine
Festplatte auch mal wegschmeißen können möchte.
Und sicherstellen will, dass niemand,
der es darauf anlegt,
dort irgendwas auslesen kann.
Garantiert!
Und mich würde es nicht wundern, wenn es schon
einige Angriffe gab, durch
weggeworfene IoT-Geräte.
100 Pro gab es da schon Probleme.
Oder du hast deine Festplatte einfach
verschlüsselt und kannst sie einfach wegschmeißen.
Das sind alles ähnliche
ähnliche Szenarien.
Man macht das aus den gleichen
Gründen.
Man schließt einfach Probleme
grundsätzlich aus mit sowas.
Es ist egal, ob jemand
das WLAN-Passwort ausschließt, es kann keiner
mehr was damit anfangen.
Wie verschlüsselt man seine Festplatte am besten?
Veracrypt.
Wenn du Microsoft vertraust, vielleicht
auch sogar BitLocker.
Oder Linux, dann ist die Sache klar.
Ich mag
Veracrypt für Windows.
Unter Linux ist es deutlich
einfacher.
Da gibt es ja schon was eingebautes.
Und unterschiedlichsten Varianten.
Auf Datei-Ebene, auf Block-Device-Ebene.
Das kann ich
mir sehr gut vorstellen.
Dass es ein riesen
Sicherheitsproblem gibt,
wo vielleicht noch nicht so viele
dran gedacht haben bisher.
Ausgemusterte IoT-Geräte.
Das ist auf jeden Fall ein Problem.
Ne, habe ich nicht gesehen.
Das hat aber letztens schon irgendjemand gepostet.
Gucken wir mal das WiFi 7 Video fertig.
... Beschreibung und für die
3003 Community gibt es...
Max, hast du das mit BitLocker mitbekommen?
Glaube schon.
Jaja, das haben wir sogar im Stream geguckt, oder?
Chatge, haben wir das nicht im Stream
schon geguckt?
Da würde ich sagen, das ist problematisch.
Aber das würde ich jetzt
tatsächlich nicht so...
Also, ja, das ist problematisch.
Sofern du ein Gerät
hast mit einem eigenen Chip.
Der Aufwand ist tatsächlich schon ein bisschen größer
und erfordert doch tiefgreifenderes
technisches Know-How.
Und du brauchst das Gerät
dafür. Aber das brauchst du in meinem
IoT-Beispiel-Fall auch.
Ja, das ist halt das Ding.
Ihr könnt euch denken, überall
wo was verschlüsselt wird
und automatisch
unlockt werden kann, irgendwo müssen
die Sachen im Klartext drin stehen.
Anders geht das nicht.
Ja genau, sobald du
eine BitLocker-Pin oder Passwort,
dass du das nicht automatisch entlocken machst,
dann hast du das Problem nicht.
Natürlich mag VeraCrypt
zum Festplattenverschlüsseln.
Das ist auch mittlerweile von der Bedienung sehr easy.
Das kriegt eigentlich jeder hin.
Und dann musst du beim Booten
von deinem Rechner ein Passwort eingeben.
Und nicht nur ein Passwort, man kann das kombinieren
mit verschiedenen Methoden.
Es gibt auch noch die Möglichkeit,
zwei Passwörter im Endeffekt
einzugeben.
Das eine ist das Passwort
und das andere ist, wie oft das Passwort
gehashed wird.
Aber
VeraCrypt ist nice.
Das ist easy zu benutzen.
Aber jedem, der VeraCrypt benutzt,
dem muss klar sein,
oder sagen wir mal so,
jedem, der ein Verschlüsselungstool verwendet,
ein gescheites
Verschlüsselungstool verwendet,
sei es jetzt VeraCrypt unter Windows
oder eingebaute Lux-Geschichte
unter Linux
oder andere NGFS im Kernel,
jeder, der gescheite
Verschlüsselungstools verwendet, dem muss klar sein,
wenn das Passwort
weg ist,
sind die Daten weg.
Das muss einem klar sein.
Und das muss so sein, sobald es eine
Recovery-Variante gibt,
wo du nicht das Passwort brauchst
oder irgendein, wie auch immer
geartetes Secret,
ist das eine Kack-Methode
für Verschlüsselung.
Wenn das Passwort weg ist
oder wenn der Schlüssel, sagen wir mal,
wenn der Schlüssel weg ist,
dann müssen die Daten verloren sein.
Sobald du es irgendwie Recoveren kannst,
ist es für den Arsch.
Deswegen war BitLocker bei mir von Anfang an
unten durch, weil das erste, was ich über BitLocker
gelesen habe, ist,
dass du irgendwie über Active Directory
und Microsoft Sachen
vergessene Sachen
Recoveren kannst.
Ja, das ist bestimmt nicht so allgemeingültig,
wie es sich damals gelesen hat.
Danke schön für den Sub.
Aber da hatte ich schon keinen Bock mehr drauf.
Ja, oder wenn du TPM-Modul
in der CPU hast,
ist es auch wieder was anderes.
Aber trotzdem, ganz ehrlich,
das Sicherste ist immer noch,
wenn ihr den Schlüssel bei euch,
also wenn ihr den Schlüssel habt
und sobald der Schlüssel weg ist,
Sergeant Silver übrigens,
dann muss es weg sein.
Anders taugt es nicht.
Recovery Key in die Cloud,
da weißt du schon mal, dass das ein doofer Ansatz ist.
Ja, ein anderer hat auch gesubbt, du aber auch.
Oder nicht?
Ach, das war schon vor 44 Minuten.
Keck, wait.
Ja, und die meisten Leute haben als Windows Passwort
dann was, ABC oder wie?
Also,
gerade wenn es um Datenträgerverschlüsselung geht,
Passwort weg, Daten weg, so muss das sein.
Oder Schlüssel weg, Daten weg.
Anders taugt nix.
Sogar 3 Monate
für den Heimpreis. Mensch,
das ist doch was. So, jetzt aber hier
erstmal genug Theorie, jetzt Praxis.
Im Test hatten wir die
Basisstation Amazon
Euromax 7.
Äh, ich hab meine gefährliche Roboter-Spinne
verloren. Hat die zufällig jemand gesehen?
Ich dachte, Krabbe.
Ein Asus GTBE98.
Das ist was für Rust-Programmierer,
das Ding.
Da ist ihr WiFi auch blazingly fast.
Ein
Netgear RS700S
und ein
Zyxel WBE660S.
Ja, ihr habt vielleicht
in den eingeblendeten Preise gesehen
zwischen 600 und 900 Euro.
Also, wirklich.
Ich sag, boah, mein Nexus Point
kostet neu einfach 1300 Euro,
aber ich kauf den ja auch nicht neu.
Und obwohl die Anschaffungspreise schon so heftig
sind, braucht man bei Amazon
und Netgear obendrein auch
noch ein Abo für bis
zu 115 Euro im Jahr.
Warum? Warum genau
brauch ich ein Abo für meinen fucking WiFi-Router?
Was hast du für
Nexus Point? Ich hab einen Rucos R710.
Zwei Stück.
Rucos.
Um bestimmte Funktionen wie die Kindersicherung
oder dynamisches DNS zu nutzen.
Warum braucht man
ein Abo? Wollen die einen verarschen
oder was? Das ist mittlerweile
so lächerlich für jeden Shit.
Ich ziemlich doof.
Muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen.
Und was man auch noch bedenken muss,
die vier Router genehmigen sich alle
ungefähr 20 Watt.
Auch ordentlich.
Hat 8 oder so.
6690, die zieht nur 11,7 Watt
aus der Steckdose. Das ist schon
ein ziemlicher Unterschied.
Das waren die Basisstationen.
Als Client haben wir einmal die WLAN-Module
Intel BE200
und Qualcomm WCN
7850 getestet.
Das sind so Steckkarten für den
Qualcomm WCN 7850 getestet.
Irgendwie
stimmen seine Lippenbewegungen nicht mehr, oder?
Guckt mal.
Stimmt noch, stimmt noch.
Und jetzt?
7850 getestet.
Irgendwas war da gerade verkehrt.
Wo man normalerweise
SSDs reintut.
Als dritten Client
haben wir einfach einen Google Pixel 8 ausprobiert
und erstaunlicherweise gibt es nämlich
schon ganz schön viele Android-Handys
mit WiFi 7 Unterstützung.
Bei Apple übrigens noch keine.
Und dann wurde hart getestet.
Mal die Frage an unseren Netzwerkexperten Ernst.
Wie hast du das denn jetzt genau gemacht?
Die neuen WiFi 7 Geräte haben wir getestet
wie alle auch vorher
mit dem iPerf3 Benchmark.
Der erlaubt uns ganz ohne Einflüsse
über die Internetleitung
echte Geschwindigkeit innerhalb des Heimnetzes
zu messen.
Das geht mit zwei PCs. Einer ist der Client,
der andere ist der Server.
Und wir messen dann eben auf drei Funkbändern
über sechs verschiedene Positionen.
Haben wir ja auch schon benutzt.
Das waren dann insgesamt knapp 400 Einzelmessungen,
die wir zu den Ergebnissen im Heft kondensiert haben.
Das kam dann dabei heraus.
Den höchsten Durchsatz schafft die Kombination
aus Netgear RS700S
und Qualcomm WCN7850
Client.
2682 Mbit
pro Sekunde aus
nahe Entfernung im 6 GHz Band.
Am schlechtesten schnitt die
Kombination aus Pixel 8
und Asus GTBE98
ab. Nur 137
Mbit aus 20...
Das ist halt ein Problem, das hast du mit Kabel nicht.
...Meter Entfernung im 2,4 GHz Band.
Wird immer beste bleiben.
So ist es einfach.
Von der Latenz, von der Störungsanfälligkeit.
Wifi hat auch seine Vorteile, da wo man sich
bewegen muss, ja, mit mobilen Clients.
Aber es wird kein Ersatz für mein
Desktop-PC werden. Außerdem ist es
ja nicht so, dass wir bei
Verkabelung irgendwie aufgehört haben.
Mittlerweile sind 2,5
GHz immer normaler.
Äh, GHz? 2,5 Gbit
immer normaler im
Heimbereich. Wie sieht es bei euch daheim aus, Leute?
Wie sieht euer
Standard-
Verkabelungsspeed daheim aus?
1 Gb, 2,5 Gb,
5, 10 oder teilweise 40
Gb noch.
Also bei mir ist es eine Mischung.
Bei mir ist es 10 Gb
und
dort, wo es keinen Sinn macht, 1 Gb.
Ich könnte theoretisch 2,5
machen, aber
an den Ports,
wo es keinen Sinn macht,
macht halt auch 2,5
keinen Sinn. Also ich habe
beispielsweise mein Desktop-PC
per 10 Gb
angeschlossen und ich habe
den
HP-Server per 1 Gb angeschlossen,
wo dann auch die
SSDs drin sind, wo ich ein bisschen Zeug hin und her kopieren kann
und sowas. Das ist per 10 Gb angeschlossen.
Drüben
beispielsweise ist Nvidia Shield
1 Gb.
Das kann auch selbst gar nicht mehr.
Internet-Star.
Der eigene
Android-Personal ist
natürlich
nicht mehr
ein
guter
Android-Prozessor,
aber
der
Android-Prozessor
Der Qualcomm-Chip lief zumindest bei uns nicht unter Linux.
Mein Fazit.
Also ich muss sagen, dass ich mit Wi-Fi 6 sowohl meine Internetleitung als auch meine Festplatten im internen Netz, also meinem Home-Server, komplett auslassen kann.
Die Platten sind nämlich nur mit USB angebunden und schaffen nur ein bisschen mehr als 100 Megabyte pro Sekunde.
Ja, da reicht ja schon ein Gigabit-Easy-Kabel.
Das entspricht 800 Mbit, also genau das, was ich mit Wi-Fi 6 hier zu Hause auch hinbekomme.
Und auch meine 1-Gigabit-LAN-Anbindung, also per Kabel, reicht für meinen Netzwerkspeicher-Kram völlig aus.
Ohnehin ist hier ja alles mit einem Gigabit-LAN angebunden, auch weil ich keine Lust habe, mir neue Switches und so weiter anzuschaffen.
Ja, und Endgeräte können das ja auch meistens nicht.
Und ehrlich gesagt, das ist das einzige Gerät, das 2,5 Gigabit per Kabel könnte, mein Desktop-PC und sonst halt nix.
Also für höhere Geschwindigkeiten brauche ich deshalb Wi-Fi 7 nicht.
Aber ich mache ja viel mit VR.
Und wenn ich PC-VR nutze, binde ich zum Beispiel meine Quest 3 über WLAN statt mit einem Kabel an.
Und das funktioniert zwar mit Wi-Fi 6 schon ziemlich gut, aber manchmal, wirklich nur manchmal, sehe ich doch noch so ein paar Artefakte.
Mit Wi-Fi 7 könnte das dann perfekt aussehen.
Und auch ganz...
Da ist auch der Vorteil, dass es eben sehr nah ist.
Ja, da könnte...
Okay, in so einem Bereich, ja, da könnte ich mir schon vorstellen, dass das sinnvoll ist.
Ja.
Da könnte ich das sehr viel versprechen, dass ich zusätzlich zu 5 Gigahertz mit Wi-Fi 7 das 6 Gigahertz-Band nutzen könnte.
Und in diesem Funkband ist in meiner direkten Nachbarschaft...
Das ging schnell, oder?
Wir haben jahrelang, ja, 10 Jahre lang oder so, haben wir, oder länger, haben wir 2,4 Gigahertz verwendet.
Ich meine, wir machen das ja immer noch.
Dann kam 5 und jetzt ein paar Jahre später schon noch 6 dabei.
Ich habe das also im besten Fall so ziemlich für mich alleine.
Ja gut, dafür könnt ihr auch auf Wi-Fi...
Aber das hat ja kein MLO und das würde ich mit Wi-Fi 7 denn noch oben drauf bekommen.
Und dieses Multi-Link-Operation hat ja nochmal das Potenzial, Stabilität und Latenz zu verbessern, weil einfach mehrere Frequenzbänder gleichzeitig genutzt werden können.
Aber ganz klar, die aktuellen Router sind mir viel zu teuer und das Ganze ist mir auch noch zu wenig ausgereift.
Außerdem kann mein aktuell genutztes Handy noch gar keinen Wi-Fi 7.
Ja, warten wir mal ein paar Jahre ab, klar.
Ja.
Ich werde Wi-Fi 7 erst haben, wenn ich gescheite Access-Points finde, die alle Features
unterstützen, die ich haben möchte und zu einem sinnigen Preis.
Wie gesagt, aktuell, ich habe es ja gerade getestet, bin ich auf 80 Mbit gekommen, vielleicht
hat sich das auch nicht in 5 GHz eingewählt, keine Ahnung.
Mein WLAN ist ja das gleiche WLAN auf 2,4 und 5 GHz, was auch immer mein iPhone da gerade
rumgespackt hat.
Aber 80 Mbit.
auf einem Handy, ist
sicherlich nicht super krass in der heutigen Zeit,
aber was kannst du damit nicht machen?
80 MBit reicht halt
für Internet surfen und Videos gucken
ohne Probleme komplett aus.
Selbst 4K,
falls man das auf einem kleinen Bildschirm sich
geben möchte.
Ich muss mir das schon langsam überlegen.
Vielleicht in 1, 2, 3 Jahren. Mal gucken,
was es da so gibt und ob ich da
wirklich konkrete Anwendungen
hinnehme. Linux-Distros laden, ja klar,
auf das iPhone, das ist logisch.
Ein Ärmel hätte. Also,
AVM hat direkt 4 neue Router
mit Wi-Fi 7 angekündigt, nachdem
der Fritzbox-Hersteller Wi-Fi
6e nicht wieder mit
Huawei-Problemen oder
War-Way einfach mal
übersprungen hat. Daran sieht man aber auch
schön, dass Wi-Fi 7 nicht
gleich Wi-Fi 7 ist, denn
Pflicht ist nur MLO, aber
nicht das 6 GHz-Band.
Also, man darf da Wi-Fi 7
draufschreiben, ohne dass die Teilen...
Oh ne, das erinnert mich ein bisschen an USB-Standards.
6 GHz können. So ist das zum Beispiel bei
Fritzbox 5690 XGS,
Cable und
7682. Sind alle
Wi-Fi 7 zertifiziert,
können aber auch alle kein 6 GHz.
Nur das Top-Modell,
Fritzbox 5690
Pro, beherrscht... Jetzt fangen die auch
schon an mit Pro dahinter, okay.
Alle drei Funkbänder. Und das Gerät soll
im Sommer für 340
Euro auf den Markt kommen. Funkbänder.
Und das
Super Vectoring
35B. So, so.
Gerät soll im Sommer für
340... Bin ich froh, dass langsam
aber sicher das Kupferkabel
den Staffelstab übergibt.
Bei uns ist
übrigens immer noch kein Glasfaserausbau
am Start. Drumherum passiert
aber vieles. Das heißt, wir werden früher oder später auch
dran kommen. Aber aktuell passt
es auch so mit meinem Kabelanschluss.
Wenn Vodafone nicht ab und zu rumspacken
würde.
Auf dem Markt kommen. Ja, wie ist das
bei euch? Seid ihr jetzt schon heiß auf
WiFi 7 oder juckt euch
das alles nicht? Gerne in die Kommentare
schreiben und den 3003 Newsletter
abonnieren und natürlich hier auf YouTube
den Channel selbst und
tschüss.
Ähm, Fritzbox wurde doch verkauft.
Ich hab nur ne News gelesen, dass
AVM verkauft...
Guck mal hier, das ist Linux
Mint und...
Alter, dass es verkauft werden
soll. Ich weiß nicht, ist das passiert?
Wurde AVM verkauft?
Noch nicht, oder?
Das hätten wir doch mitbekommen.
Noch nicht, ja, noch nicht.
Was wird uns denn empfohlen
hier auf YouTube nochmal, bevor wir
jetzt hier durch...
durch Klicks hornen?
Keine Pumpe.
Der Auer.
Die bräuchte den Anzeigen
Hauptmeister.
Irgendwie nix dabei, oder?
Die Partnervermittlung. Für mich, ja, weißt du,
ich hab's nötig, wieder
Dating und Partnersuche. Ohne App, so
arbeitet eine Partnervermittlerin. Boah, nee,
eigentlich hab ich da gar keinen Bock drauf jetzt.
Was ist das? Apothekerin enthüllt
Gehalt. Viel Verantwortung, hartes Studium, genug
Geld. Also, meine
Erfahrung mit Apotheken war eher, dass die
Leute dort komplett planlos sind.
Ist bestimmt wie bei allem.
90%
der Leute sacken halt und das hat
man dann im Hinterkopf, aber es gibt auch durchaus ein paar
Schlaue und Fähige.
Leute, ich hab übertrieben Hunger.
Da sollen noch ein paar
Punkte, noch ein paar Folgen kommen. Nice.
Das war nicht schlecht.
Nächste guck ich mir
auch an. Was gibt's zu essen? Tja,
Chat, was könnte es zu
essen geben? Schwere
Frage. Nudeln mit
Lachs. Es gibt
zwei Varianten. Es könnte Nudeln
mit Lachs geben oder Nudeln mit Tomatensauce
und Hackfleisch.
Gags mit
Fudeln. Ja, das könnte es
auch sein.
Aber ihr habt natürlich recht.
Gib Nudeln mit Lachs. Korrekt.
So sieht das aus.
Ja.
Letztes. Es ist eigentlich ganz easy.
Letzte Woche gab's Nudeln mit Tomatensauce.
Also gibt's heute Nudeln mit Lachs.
Iiiiz.
Wer macht denn sowas?
Was ist eigentlich
für exzellente Fishhead Musik
im Hintergrund?
Stream Ende. Ja. Und?
Ich
glaube, ich muss heute weiter MMO
Kreiselcry machen.
Event geht heute bis 24 Uhr noch.
Sind schon alle wieder am rumweinen.
Schlimm.
MMO-Communities ist das...
Nee, so spannend ist das für Leute, die das Game nicht kennen.
MMO-Communities sind echt die Schlimmsten.
Die Leute sind immer am heulen.
Wegen allem wird geheult.
So, ich geh jetzt was fordern.
Leute, wir hören uns bis dann.
Macht's gut.
See you.